your time
[Music]
13. o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody what's going on it's
Wednesday night
Tom's here his beard is here yep
mostly it's the mustache you can see on
yeah I got a camera but you do have the
beard as well and I am wigless today I'm
actually like rocking my actual hair
I just said I was so tired today I was
just like I don't I don't even feel like
uh
I don't even feel like wearing away
today you know what I mean but my hair
is actually not that short it's just I
have it pulled back like in a ponytail
back there because like I said it's kind
of hot in here
so you know it's actually likes it so
that's good everybody's starting to come
in yeah how's everybody doing you got an
interesting this we got we got spiced
rum and ginger ale today yeah somebody
suggested it it's pretty good
this is Evan's already party said Jenny
you look so pretty thank you very much
we're gonna have a
spooky space show today
about space programs and astronauts Lost
in Space and well lots and getting
killed and stuff like that because I
actually didn't realize but it is
um
considering how dangerous it is to go
into space I you know I imagine
um they haven't really lost all that
many astronauts there's really only
three that technically died in space
like they have some that they have a
bunch that died I think it's 19 as the
official account but most of them died
either on re-entry or on launch
Americans pretty much though no
um cosmonauts also all right yeah I
wouldn't believe a word the Soviet
silver well that's I want to get into
that too because
um a lot of the stuff from back then
that was has been Declassified like
because there was some stuff that they
kept secret but they know about it now
they probably lost hundreds well I don't
know like I said I don't know because uh
you know but we'll get into that when we
get into talking about last lost
cosmonauts and all that kind of stuff
but I'll probably save that to last but
like I said there there is some stuff
that happened in the Soviet Union like
back then like people that usually
during training and then they're one was
one that was like really horrifying
um or actually there were a couple that
were like really horrifying but they
kind of lied about it at the time but
then like later on like now they know
about it but
you know they now everything's been uh
Declassified so everybody knows about it
now but you know what I mean I like the
term uh Danny Rowling says I like the
term Cosmonaut better than astronaut it
sounds cooler it does doesn't it I mean
you know what are you gonna do
uh let's see the Chinese went to the
dark side of the moon
there is no Dark Side of the Moon
well it's dark from our yeah from our
Viewpoint well when the sun it's also
dark from
the darkness goes all the way around it
phases of the moon yeah it's all dark
that's just like that's exactly what
they said in the damn
on the uh on the on the Pink Floyd album
Dark Side of the Moon because there's no
Dark Side of the Moon really it's all
dark
it's all dark it's just you know so deep
man yeah it's all dark yeah the front of
it gets dark
you know I wouldn't [ __ ]
when the moon gets plotted out
this is Evan's Arty party said I'm a
teacher and I'll never forget the
teacher that died on the Challenger
crash yeah I want to talk about that a
little bit too because I vividly
remember when the Challenger uh
explosion happened interestingly it
happened you know how I always remember
the date because it was my little
brother's 10th birthday and he freaked
the [ __ ] out because it was his birthday
and he thought that I mean he was only
10. and he thought that like it was
somehow like to do with him like the
shuttle exploding you know what I mean
but I remember like being in school I
didn't see it happen on TV we saw it
later but like some people had seen it
because I think we were at lunch or
something
but then like when we were coming back
to the classroom I think I was in junior
high
yeah 86 I was in junior high so we were
coming back and somebody said the
shuttle explode and we're like [ __ ] off
you didn't they did not like we thought
they were kidding not vaporized but then
yeah I mean it didn't necessarily
vaporize it like it blew up but
they uh yeah it was pretty [ __ ] up it
was pretty [ __ ] up
uh but yeah we'll talk about that and
then I'd forgotten that the Columbia
also exploded in 2003 so I wanted to
talk about that too early on re-entry
burned up yeah so that's what I mean I
kind of feel like a lot of the astronaut
deaths
happened during like you know shortly
after launch or during re-entry mostly
um not that many happened like in space
you know what I mean well
based based on some of the stuff that I
saw when it came to the Russian Space
Program it was secret you only heard
about missions that survived you know
what I mean excuse me you only heard
about missions that were successful
um I think they it was people believe
that a lot of guys were killed during
the training and testing because they
had a bunch of
they had a bunch of launch pad
explosions we never heard about you know
I mean they kept it quiet
well I have some of those like I said
it's all been Declassified now so I do
have some of those they admit to how
many people died
um well there was a bunch that I found
like I said you know so we'll get into
that in a little bit so it's it seems
like it's common knowledge nowadays but
yeah back then they did actually try to
keep it a secret but not not So Much
Anymore
um Danny Rowling said supposedly there's
a conspiracy theory about the Challenger
crash that the astronauts faked their
deaths and are still alive of course
yeah they're hanging out with Elvis yeah
I'm sure and Bigfoot yeah that's [ __ ]
up yeah I mean all these people are dead
that's not funny you know what I mean
and they die to like the most horrible
[ __ ] way possible yeah I think they
screamed all the way down didn't they
um some of those no no
um I don't I don't know if that's if
that was like a later urban legend okay
basically I don't know I guess we can
talk about that but um all they have on
tape uh they said is one of them they're
like basically they just heard one of
them go uh oh and then like it blew up
now they think that they were still
alive like when because when the thing
came off like they it kind of went up
and that you know the front where they
were wasn't like detached but they think
that the depressurization was so quick
that they probably died like within 40
seconds yeah like before so it wasn't
like they were like all the way down to
the ocean you know because I mean I hope
not because I've been [ __ ] horrifying
but it probably happened
quickly you know what I mean like before
they before impact like I said I hope so
because depressurization and we'll talk
about a couple of those because there
are a couple of those really [ __ ] up
cases that happened like that like
including a Soviet one
um usually that happens within like 20
to 40 seconds you know what I mean yeah
and if you're
if you're re-entering
and the hull or the cabin gets
compromised a jet of super hot flames
gonna come through there and just kill
everybody pretty much pretty instantly
it won't it wouldn't cook you you know
what I mean it would kill you
that's how I that's how hot it would be
it's coming down at like what mach 16
yeah something so you know it's just
might as well just shine a damn laser
beam in there
[ __ ] you up
yeah I mean yeah Zach said there's so
much existential stuff about outer space
that scares me like how far does space
go what if we're existing in a giant box
or something well I think that the
reason that a lot of people because I
found like a bunch of videos
um about this kind of topic and I think
it's just because even though not that
we know of that it hasn't really
happened because that now they have like
fail safes against it
but just the idea of like I said doing
like a Major Tom and kind of being out
in space and then getting detached like
if you're on a spacewalk or something
they're just drifting off in his base
and it would take you a while
um to die you know what I mean because
if you were still in your spacesuit I
was watching like a video earlier and
they said well if that happened they're
like obviously you know they have all
kind of stuff now like nowadays they
even have like a little uh button on the
suit that automatically takes you back
to the space station or whatever the
hell so they have that now because they
developed that but they have like
tethers and they're Tethered to each
other and all of a sudden they have jet
packs and all this other kind of stuff
to kind of keep that from happening but
um they said you know if it did happen
you would probably be floating around
out there for like seven and a half
hours like until your oxygen ran out and
you'd like just be out there going huh
like just looking at the Blackness it
wouldn't be much to look at yeah like
for seven and a half I can't even
imagine
I'm moving that's horrifying you
wouldn't even have a sensation of
movement you just feel like you were
sitting still
yeah well that's what in a way that to
me like that makes it even more horrible
yeah because you just be like sitting
there in a [ __ ] like you were in some
kind of limbo State yeah
that's Blackness bunch of stars no not
even moving I'm not cut out to be an
astronaut sorry
that's what I'm saying oh that would be
awful so I can really see how that's
like a really creep that's some creepy
[ __ ] that like people
think about because that's like a really
I just can't imagine what that would be
like I can't imagine what that would be
like Zach said the idea that there are
black holes moving through the Universe
on their own is one of my most upsetting
Concepts along with super volcanic
eruptions and brain aneurysms yeah it
can happen anytime
yeah and that's I mean
statistically it's probably unlikely so
it's probably like not worth worrying
about but I mean I think I of those I
think I'd be more worried about a brain
aneurysm because I've out of those three
just off the top of my head that's
probably the most likely to happen to
you specifically
um and even then it's probably not that
you know not that statistically likely
but
I mean
there's a lot of stuff out there one of
the things that's out there is rogue
planets these are these are gas giants
size of Jupiter or bigger that were
thrown out of solar systems during their
formation
well they're just out there and some of
them have their own moons around them
kind of like little miniature solar
systems
well we could be mining on our own
business and I think something like that
could go right through our damn solar
system and pull the Earth off of its
orbit and we would just become a rogue
Planet
let's go out of the Blackness of space
yep
I mean I'm kind of like morbidly
fascinated by that kind of stuff but
I mean because I think well it's like I
said there's not much Point worrying
about it because it's probably not gonna
happen at least not in our lifetimes I
mean it would be really unlikely I'm not
saying it can't it can but
it's just like really I got like
millions of other things to worry about
that like it's it's all on the Spectrum
you know it was real likely it would
have happened already billions of years
ago because there's a lot of time in the
past
so it hasn't happened in the past
so chances are it won't happen in our
future at least in our lifetime
that's the thing too is that you have to
think like in the greens in the grand
scheme of things like a human lifetime
is very very short so the likelihood of
something that catastrophic like
happening in any one person's uh
lifetime is like probably like infinite
infinites absolutely small but like it's
like like I said I'm not saying that it
can't it's just like not really worth
worrying about there's a million other
things you should probably be worrying
about that are a lot more likely you
know you can see it coming
yeah once it got out to like Pluto and
close closer it it would start shining
you're you're the the Sun's light would
hit it
and astronomers would pick it up they're
like what the [ __ ] is that that thing's
bigger than Jupiter oh [ __ ] it's coming
right for us
it'll be here in five years
yeah imagine that
yep it's like well everybody party down
for the next five years because we're
probably getting sucked into a black
hole
big old Rogue planet's gonna go to be
honest I kind of feel like and I pray I
think most people probably feel the same
way I'm like if some [ __ ] like that is
gonna happen I would just rather it
happen without any pre like warning
because you don't want to know that
shit's coming you know what I mean that
would be super depressing
like they said there were some black
holes that could just appear out of
nowhere too well yeah me and Tech that
is theoretically possible sure yeah Camp
guy said we wouldn't even know if we got
hit with a black hole or if the sun
blows up
yeah we probably wouldn't I mean it
would just be like so quick that well it
would have gravitational power so we
start
it would start warping the uh it would
probably start warping the um
the orbits of the planets
as it was coming in you detect it
probably yeah yeah like I said I think
I'd rather like I don't know how big it
was I mean if some big like [ __ ]
earth-shattering [ __ ] was gonna happen
like that I would rather just be like a
weird [ __ ] gamma burst or some [ __ ]
like that that just was like phew it
just like blew everything up and nobody
knew what was happening like yeah I
don't really want to know it's like hey
there's an asteroid that's gonna come
hit the earth like a year from now like
so and we're probably all dead so have
fun with that you know what I mean so I
don't know that seems like not a lot of
fun grampler says statistically uh oh
and hold my beer and watch are the two
most common pre-death braces yeah I I
admit like I know I feel like a bad
person
um but when I read that about like the
Challenger thing that like that was the
only
that was the only thing that they heard
over the thing like some of like one of
them just saying uh-oh and then like I
was just like yeah uh-oh that's that's
true
uh yeah Knox says uh y'all saving the
day for me work is a drag thank you Tom
and Jenny well you're very very welcome
we just we like being here drinking our
little spice rum talking about space and
astronauts and [ __ ] like that you know
yep
Grandfather said if the Earth were to go
off orbit and become a lifeless ball of
ice we would simply join the billions of
other lifeless rocks floating around in
the cosmos yep pretty much you could
probably go down into a mine shaft and
take a lot of stuff with you and live
for a while
grow plants and stuff
like out of Dr Strangelove
yeah there you go yeah because you don't
need you don't need atmosphere warmth
you go down deep enough man it's hot
it's hot
grow some mushrooms yeah
just the Earth's core itself can stay
warm
fourth throw down says as long as Bruce
Willis is still alive when it comes
we'll be okay that's right
that's right he was an art that was
Armageddon right
was I never saw it it's all right I
never saw it yeah it was just kind of
like that was the whole premise of
Armageddon but it's been a long time
since I've seen it it was 90s right that
was 98 I want to say I don't know yeah
it was just like about yeah oh there's a
big planet killing asteroid and like
they have to send Bruce Willis up there
to like well not Bruce Willis still like
his character and a team and they have
to send it up there to like didn't they
have to like have a nuke to you know put
it off the course so it wouldn't hit the
Earth or something I don't know it's
been a long time so actually Bruce
Willis that they sent because Bruce
Willis played himself
in all those movies just play himself
so now that's like NASA has Bruce Willis
like on the red phone right there like
in case we have some like Planet killing
asteroid there's like call Bruce Willis
I don't know what to do
oh my God that would be so [ __ ] funny
uh Camp guy said the space shuttle had a
1 in 100 failure prediction so all these
astronauts knew they were riding the
bullet yeah I kind of feel like to even
want to be an astronaut in the first
place it's kind of like that I think
that's why they recruited a lot of them
from like people that were test pilots
because these were people that were
pretty comfortable I don't know if they
were comfortable with the fact but they
were pretty cognizant of the fact that
yeah I could die this time and they were
like okay with it it seemed like the
whole Space Shuttle was dumb as [ __ ]
anyway it didn't make the space shuttle
didn't make any sense it didn't carry
much of a damn cargo you're carrying the
shuttle up and down and up and down just
a waste of time they should have just
taken the Saturn V booster rockets and
then just built different tops for them
and it would have been well they
eventually did do that I kind of feel
like the problem was that in the 70s I
think would I think it was Nixon yeah
that approved the space shuttle program
and they were like yeah we can just use
these shuttles and go back and forth and
we could take everything up there it's
defense stuff or scientific stuff or
whatever the [ __ ] needs to go up there
and it seemed like it works that like
well for a little while but I kind of
feel like they were putting too much
stress like on NASA it's like we have to
have this many flights like every year
and it's like they weren't really
getting enough money to do that you know
what I mean so it just kind of seemed
like they had to kind of cut corners and
they didn't really have it and you know
in it it ended up with you know in
disaster a couple of times yeah the
shuttle weighed a lot sure it was good
it was going up and down and it it
didn't have much Cargo in it they didn't
use Saturn Rockets you know that Saturn
V rocket that they went to the Moon with
yeah those bought the bottom few
stages were heavy lift stages and you
can just put a different top on it you
know what I mean and that would have
been your space shuttle basically yeah
you didn't need you know what I mean and
it could have been purpose built just it
was a heavy lift booster and for some
reason they
they didn't want to stick with that
heavy lift booster that they had they
would have had a lot more [ __ ] up in
space for a lot cheaper if they just
stayed with the heavy lift booster yeah
you could put people on it but just
bring them down in capsules you don't
need that
that big huge that big coin bus yeah
space bus no
yeah you have a some kind of working
module that stays up there in orbit and
it becomes part of a space station and
if you want to bring the crew down they
come down in a little re-entry
little little like disposable re-entry
module you know like it like they always
did they came down in a little capsule
it was like a castle they were trying to
be like [ __ ] fancy you're trying to
be too fancy yes yeah and like I said it
was it seemed like they were trying to
be too bad I don't know whose idea it
was but they they were trying to be too
fancy and then they were like well we
want you to do this that and the other
thing but we're not going to give you
enough money to do that like effectively
so you're gonna like I said you're gonna
have to cut corners and it's like it was
a fake space plane they wanted it to
appear as a space plane but that's not a
space plane a space plane
takes off at a on a on a
on an airstrip flies up into the air
and then goes into orbit
and then uh goes into space and then
Lance a single stage you know
that's a space plan
for some reason they wanted the space
shuttle to be kind of like a space plane
it didn't make any sense
it was bad yeah I mean in hindsight yeah
I mean they did do a lot of successful
missions I'm not doing that but I mean
they did go back and forth a lot
expensive and inefficient but it was
very expensive and inefficient well and
the thing I don't know if you guys know
but like but you know I grew up in
Florida like I grew up in Daytona Beach
so starting in the 80s like late or like
the early 80s every time pretty much
every time there was a space shuttle
launch like my parents would drive us
down to Cape Canaveral which was only
about 50 miles from where I grew up and
we would go and like and go to the
launch pad and watch it so I saw a lot
of them I wasn't like I said I wasn't
there at the Challenger one because I
was at school and like I saw it on TV
but we saw I saw
um Columbia go up in 1981 I think when I
was nine years old like from the launch
pad like we saw we drove down there and
saw it uh Dave is here hey what's up uh
hey yo you two been busy hey okay how
are you doing yeah it's Wednesday night
so I guess
do you have a minute do you go to
mannequins tonight Wednesday is not
karaoke is it or is it I can't remember
what Night karaoke is or if they're
still doing that Zach said wasn't there
some news a few years ago about Tom
Cruise getting ready to shoot a movie on
bars oh God imagine the Scientologist
colonizing a planet well as long as they
get the [ __ ] off this one then that
would be fine with me Tom Cruise yeah go
colonize Mars just get out of our face
yes Tom's not deliver man
he's like I can fly an airplane I'm
going to bars
I won't be happy unless I have Tom
Cruise and he has a jet pack and he just
takes everybody up there like
individually yeah one by one
of the jet pack yeah okay hey he's a
badass he has magic OT Powers come on he
could do it you're gonna sleep the whole
way yeah
nine months I'm gonna go to Mars like
riding on top Christmas yeah
you gotta send me to Mars man I could
sleep that whole time nine months no
problem [ __ ] just give me blanket I
[ __ ] sleep I believe you could sleep
for nine months yeah oh yeah I'd wake up
you know to eat go to the bathroom go
back to sleep well I hope so yeah
otherwise you'd starve to death or you'd
suffocate under your uh waist
man I should have pulled out pictures of
my granddad for this
well why didn't you I know I've been
thinking about it I wasn't thinking
about it my granddad
Charlie Weems
was the aerospace engineer and uh he
worked for
McDonald Douglas Grumman Aerospace
and the general atomics he was on and he
was on the Saturn project
uh helped build the F4 uh F-15 Tomcat no
F-14 Tomcat
he did the fuel injection system to that
on the Saturn V rockets on the boosters
Rockets he engineered all the electronic
systems and the explosive bolt systems
to separate the stages
um did he did all kinds of [ __ ]
he uh
most of most of it was down there in
California
this is where he was working
but one of the most interesting ones
that he was on I didn't find out until
much later and I found out through my
uncle his name is Charlie Charlie Weems
so it was like you know his dad
I didn't know it but he was he worked at
General atomics on the [ __ ]
project Orion which is a
nuclear external combustion rocket
and uh he was working on that
because he was good with explosives
explosives and rigging explosives and
that was part of the
part of the test rigs involved [ __ ]
high explosive pellets
blast this [ __ ] up into the air and they
had evidently had a bunch of working
models according to he never told me
about it
um
but his son my uncle Charlie told me
some of the crazy [ __ ]
that they were doing on that project
they told me over the phone much later
after a lot of that [ __ ] was
Declassified
um
my granddad told him some of the stuff
they were working on
but when that
when Orion was going to be ready you
could launch it from a barge out the
middle of the ocean
and it would just leave
it would leave Earth's atmosphere riding
on a dab wave of [ __ ] nuclear plasma
and once it was up there it just stayed
up there
and it had a nuclear power plant in it
that came out of uh the submarines that
they were building
so it had a lot it had a lot of electric
power and everything was just all
mechanical you didn't even have
computers
mechanical computers and the engine was
mechanical the engine was just uh the
glorified Coke bottle machine it would
just throw [ __ ] three atomic bombs
out the back of it per second
and the bombs were the size of like a
tuna can
and they went through and [ __ ]
electromagnetic field to arm and then it
went through another one to
to to light the fuse and they did they
detonated like just a split second later
behind the craft there was a big shock
absorber to absorb the [ __ ] blast
you could get to Saturn in [ __ ] a
month I think it was Jupiter or Saturn
in a month it was fast real fast you had
to thrust half the way there turn it
around and then [ __ ] thrust to slow
down to arrive but it was we'd have been
putted all over this [ __ ] solar
system had they made those
but Kennedy killed it
you know what's weird my grandfather
also worked for NASA yeah in Florida
for a long time yeah he was an
electrician he didn't directly work for
NASA he worked for the contractors that
NASA was hiring
now my grandfather worked at actual
worked at Nasa yeah like in Cocoa Beach
yeah he used to commute there for like
years and years before he retired
they were making weird [ __ ] back in the
60s 50s and 60s and [ __ ] that'll never
see the light of day
um and uh
just
you know some of it just rumored
and Charlie just told me that something
was you know nuclear-powered aircraft
that kind of stuff
which that was like a all kind of treaty
violations but they were doing it anyway
your nuclear-powered bombers
was one of the things that they were
working on
Dave said uh yeah he's going to
mannequins they have a Gong Style Show
like Gong Show for cash and then they
have karaoke afterward
we haven't been to mannequins in a while
actually but you know
uh I need to go yeah Friday one of these
days you know what is this weekend and I
totally forgot is um Absolution in Tampa
but
I mean that's kind of a long drive
they're letting us in for free because I
did all the posters and stuff but yeah
Mark's saying when they're rumors about
a cult with the early Aerospace what
you're talking about is you're talking
about
um
L Ron Hubbard
uh [ __ ] Anton LaVey and then that
other crazy rocket scientist that was
they were all friends who Jack Parsons
Jack Parsons He was always blowing
himself up I think he eventually blew
himself up till he died didn't he did we
do we did a show about Jack Parsons did
we not I thought we did yeah and they
were in a wife swapping and they were
trying to bring in they're a bunch of
weirdos
[ __ ] they were into wife swapping and
they were trying to [ __ ] breed to his
that's cataract from [ __ ] Dune or
something you know yeah it was like some
[ __ ] like that basically [ __ ] like that
you know it was weird
kids are trapping
um probably literally yeah
yeah there's a lot of stuff that people
don't realize there's not only there's a
science and Drug connection
um a lot of the a lot of the scientists
nuclear physicists and engineers
were getting involved with LSD
to see if they could come up with new
ideas and new inventions and it was
working yeah like I said that's not
that's not crazy yeah it worked so yeah
and this it was a CIA that asked them to
do it so it's not like they pulled that
out of their ass to see the CIA
was big into drug research and they were
into mind expansion
so they were trying to figure out the
proper dosage that you could give to a
scientist to give it more inspiration
nowadays it still exists like in big
Tech and some of these industries yeah
that's right tiny doses of
that doesn't like [ __ ] you up but it's
supposed to kind of like but to free
simulate your free up your [ __ ]
imagination yeah your freedom of thought
and stuff
I don't know if it works I think it's
better just to get blasted
I could totally blasted have religious
experiences and visions and
hallucinations and and and have
something something Dawn on you and
that's how all the Beatles music was
generated basically just tripping balls
all the good Beatles music you know yeah
same thing with cure
good cure music is [ __ ] heavily LSD
inspired
I will say that you know yeah that's
good but I do kind of feel like some of
the LSD stuff was
um I didn't love it you know what I mean
like with some bands I mean oh okay that
were all like well no some people if
you're not any good then you're not good
then that's not gonna help you
you gotta have to have talent right
right and the Beatles were already good
right so that's just like you know kind
of Amplified yeah if you suck I mean
it's done yeah you're gonna end up being
the Grateful Dead that's who I was
thinking of actually they sucked no I
mean no hate on people that like the
Grateful Dead I know a lot of people do
but I'm just gonna it sucked I kind of
feel like
well
you kind of have to be high to be into
the Grateful Dead to start with and it's
just kind of like I don't know I just
can't get it it just seems like a little
this drum circle [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
what I mean they just seem like a little
too self-satisfied for me for my taste
that's all like I'm not hating if you
like them but I'm just really not into
it um
Danny Rowling said uh that 2009 film
moon was a decent astronaut film
starring Sam Rockwell I love that movie
and you know what I don't think that we
have reviewed that that's another one
that we probably should because I love
that [ __ ] movie you've seen it right
you saw Moon yeah it was great yeah
that's a great [ __ ] movie
but you see uh I'm I'm still pissed over
project Orion had they made those
and I think they had an order for about
eight of them they'd still be up there
today
and they'd be totally modern nowadays
you could re they'd have them all
outfitted with modern computers and you
could keep them refueled with regular
rockets and
SpaceX Rockets could take all their
[ __ ] nuclear fuel that they needed
and we would have [ __ ] totally
explored the solar system by now with
those all the moons around Jupiter and
Saturn we would have been to them all
had they done that it had been well
worth it it did leave
nuclear waste into the atmosphere
launching them but they did the math and
launching all of them still would have
been a fraction of of all the all the
all the radiation that was left in the
atmosphere from the nuclear above ground
testing that they were doing so it
wouldn't have made any difference
not in the big picture you know so just
for exploration they should have just
done it because it wouldn't have made
any difference
because we were exploding [ __ ] atomic
bombs on the surface anyway during that
period
and each launch was only equivalent to
like one of those bombs and I think we
let off like a 40 or 50 of them it would
have made any difference
Caitlin Higgin said did you guys hear
about the space hotel that's supposedly
under construction and set to launch in
2025.
I think I kind of heard something about
that but I don't really know like any of
the details or anything like that yeah
he's a slightly highly unlikely that's
it space Hotel
yeah under construction no
I don't know I don't see it happening
that's even I'm going to spend money to
be floating around
John rumbleslap says Grateful Dead Fish
Dave Matthews Band and black crows had a
festival in 1994 and they're still
playing to this day yeah see
that I mean that sounds like
I don't know man that sounds like a like
the lineup for Mel like I said I know
people like that it's just like it's
just not my thing it just seems like a
little bit too much like
let's all drop acid and then we're gonna
sit here and like Noodle around on
[ __ ]
our instruments for five hours and every
video and I'm just like I don't know it
just seems really boring it seems really
boring that's all
uh Zach says by the way can you imagine
sleeping in zero gravity I'd kill to try
that yeah I kind of wonder about I mean
I'm not going into space because [ __ ]
that it's just kind of like
you know you got me a weenie if you want
to but I'm not going into space and I'm
not going to the bottom of the ocean I
don't really need to go to either of
those places I'm sure it's like not fun
and it's like really scary and I don't
think so
um but I don't know it would be kind of
nice to be able to sleep and not
I have like uncomfortable there's just
like no pressure anywhere that might
actually be kind of nice but
they can simulate that like on Earth
though so
I don't want to have to go in space to
do it
all right so do you want to get started
on this go ahead and do on this thing
although probably talk for a minute
because I kind of should go to the
bathroom first yeah
all right I'll tell you I'll tell you
why they uh went ahead and they canceled
that
Orion because I remember what it was now
thank you
General atomics had the damn models laid
out of all the different versions that
they were going to make
and the uh
John F Kennedy came down and looked at
all the models and he was looking at the
specs he just he just thought the [ __ ]
was cool
he went to the last one
and it was basically like
a battleship
it had
like a turd on the side of it like
something out of awful [ __ ] bat like
off of old [ __ ] World War II
battleship
and it had uh cannons
that could uh shoot out
atomic bombs
back towards the Earth
and it was uh basically a [ __ ] Death
Star it was like a nuclear orbital
battle station
and JFK is like well [ __ ] is this you
know they're like yeah it's a nuclear
attack battle station
um and he goes who's this for and he
goes and it was like well the Air Force
has already ordered four of them
and he's like oh hell no
because uh
JFK was like [ __ ] the Soviet sea or
see that [ __ ] they're gonna [ __ ]
they might launch or they're going to
build their own then there's going to be
a big [ __ ] nuclear space race
so he just killed the whole [ __ ]
program I don't think he should have
done it even Carl Sagan said that was
some stupid [ __ ] that they never should
have stopped that program
they just should have made it illegal to
weaponize them you know make like a a
treaty not to not to weaponize those
spacecraft
maybe sold a couple to Russia so they'd
be happy you know something like that
so they could have their own
Danny rolling said the film Elysium is a
sick film about the poor living on a
wasteland of Earth while the Rich and
Famous live in a man-made space station
like the infamous Flintstones Jetsons
cartoon conspiracy yeah we saw that
movie didn't we Elysium I thought we saw
it
I'm pretty sure we saw that
John rumbleslaw says space is the bottom
of the ocean it's a loop yeah that's
kind of how I feel about it well they do
um like Astronaut training they train
them like under water because it's like
similar you know what I mean they have
like all they have like a um I think
that the lab where they train the
astronauts like to do spacewalks and
[ __ ] like that it's like in this big
huge pool and they built like a
a replica of the space station or
whatever it is that they have to do on
that mission and they like build it
underwater and then you have to do it
like in all your gear and all that kind
of [ __ ] because it's kind of similar you
know I mean uh has anyone seen Apollo 18
um I haven't seen it but I watched a
video about it for some reason oh I
think it was because it was Ryan
Hollinger and I always watch his videos
even if I haven't seen the movie that
he's talking about and he did talk about
that movie and he I think a lot of
people didn't like it but I think that
he kind of liked it it looked kind of
good you know what I mean so I was like
I don't know I might get around to like
watching it one of the best space movies
we ever saw was me and Jen saw
a documentary in the theater a couple
years ago it was called Apollo 11 wasn't
it
I think it was yeah
and it was the moon shot all real
all the footage I didn't even realize
that they had like that much footage all
the footage all the audio there wasn't
anything really
fake about it and they just and I I felt
like I went to the [ __ ] Moon watching
that it did really feel like that yeah
we saw it in the theater and it was just
I was like oh my God that was like one
of the best documentaries I ever saw it
was exciting as hell
and throughout the whole mission it
would come up and they would explain
what's going to happen there would be
old 1960s diagrams of the ship rolling
over and things unfolding and things
reach an escape velocity and how that
was going to happen and it was like some
dude from back in NASA in 69 telling you
how it was going to go down and I felt
like it was backwards I was back when I
was like two months old that's how old I
was during that launch I'm two months
old I'm going to the Moon that's right
that's right 1969 man you tell me we're
going
back whatever you do well it's just
funny because I mean even like everybody
knows like how that mission turned out
obviously but even so like when you
watch the documentary it's still like
really suspenseful yeah like you're like
oh [ __ ] this might not work out it's
like oh yeah it did work out but yeah
and all those dudes all those dudes were
[ __ ] like my grandpa which are this
pocket protector white boys with the
birth control glasses and the [ __ ]
voices and the ties yeah
that's right
Airlines and today we'll reach this in a
bit of just going on like that you know
and here we go it's four zero Niner and
today on the fourth year we will launch
and launching the eagle it will launch
you know like it sounded they sounded
like that you know
pocket protector
nerdy [ __ ] didn't have a
calculator they pull out that [ __ ]
what was that thing that they called
what was that thing that they used oh
yeah I know what you're talking about I
didn't have calculators
it was a round disc and it would turn
and then it's a slide rule yeah it's
like a slide rule was one of them and
then they had those little round discs
that they could turn it
mechanical computers I mean that was
like some hardcore [ __ ] back then
everything's so easy right nowadays
back then they had to figure some [ __ ]
out you talk to those [ __ ] you
had to have a pen in your hand
that's right in your hand and they were
gonna pull out a [ __ ] Slide Rule and
they're gonna pull up one of those
little plastic [ __ ] discs that they'd
rotate that's the only way you can talk
to them
true that's what it's funny that it's
like they looked
it's just kind of like whenever you see
kind of like those old
um you know kind of uh like shorts and
stuff like from the 60s like the 50s and
60s like all the dudes in that looked
exactly the same it's almost like they
all came out of a factory here yeah they
all look like Japanese guys y'all dress
like Japanese guys they all had like the
same like shirts and like you said the
pocket protectors and the glasses and
the receding hairline yeah the little
ponchy little white section yeah two
little ties and everything and they were
a short sleeve dress shirts
you know with a watch
yeah yeah because you had to have a
watch back yeah I kind of feel like most
people don't wear watches nowadays
because it's on your phone yeah why the
[ __ ] you need one yeah I mean unless you
like want to impress people yeah
everybody's like you're [ __ ] funny
man who cares
go to the [ __ ]
the nightclub and the nightclub and
those days had booths and a stage
cigarette girls walking around pom-poms
on their booties
and then they would just write down
secret [ __ ] and designs for [ __ ] how
to break the sound barrier on a [ __ ]
dinner napkin they'd be drawing that
[ __ ] out like that and then they'd curl
it up and throw it oh don't you throw
that pick that up
and set it on fire and [ __ ] you know see
[ __ ] gotta write [ __ ] down on a
napkin
while they're drinking scotch
that's how they worked man and having a
nice blue steak
[Laughter]
some 18 year old girl with Pom-Pom on
her booty like a little [ __ ] bunny
rabbit do you remember those you
remember those little frilly [ __ ]
things that they wear yeah they're
frilly underwear with little short mini
skirt yeah [ __ ] that's out of the 60s
waitress waitresses yeah I remember I
remember it
it's like classy restaurants like the
Velvet turtle and [ __ ] The Velvet Turtle
yeah Danny rolling selling some dad
jokes if athletes get athletes but what
do astronauts get mistletoe uh why
they're not war dog astronauts they're
afraid of the vacuum you know what
something like [ __ ] up that I kind of
heard while I was researching this show
is that you know like um like this is
like terrible this kind of upsets me a
lot but you know how they sent animals
up in space like before they sent people
of its base like dogs and monkeys and
stuff
um apparently some of those animals are
still like out there floating around
yeah dead like obviously and
um every now and then like some
astronauts like human astronauts that go
up there like on a mission we'll see one
like kind of floating by like hey it's
dead for the dog or whatever that's
right that's what I heard that they
still like but that they still like see
them like how'd the dog get out well no
I'm saying like in the capsule oh
they're just like oh that's like the
dead dog in The Capsule that's still
like going around the earth or whatever
that was like that's that's [ __ ] up
for some reason that upsets me more than
like the people die those would be worth
something one day you'll probably
retrieve them Jesus Christ
because they'll be relics space jump
it's funny
yeah there's all kind of I mean please
jump there's all kind of crap like
floating around up there And Justice For
Me says I worked for a government
contractor and we had our share of
Engineers brilliant people but a lot of
them had the social skills of offense
pose well yeah I mean that's the thing
they kind of have like more important
[ __ ] to do I guess which is yeah that's
fair enough I don't think it was this
bad back in the 60s though I can show
you pictures of my granddad
um and it's because uh they didn't
really have nerd culture nerds were kind
of it was it was
normal guys could be nerdy a matter of
fact normal dudes were supposed to be
kind of nerdy back then they didn't
really have cool guys
there was no such thing as cool guys not
really as cool as you're gonna get us
like if you watch [ __ ] if you watch like
yeah
yeah
that's the way it was yeah that that
like my granddad was not in the [ __ ]
um uh the age of Aquarius generation you
know what I mean he was already too old
so he was like something out of the 40s
like some out of World War II
and um
they uh
they were just kind of formal and nerdy
and kind of stiff like as cool as
they're gonna get is like if you saw on
Dr Strangelove you know the man like
[ __ ] a general Bucky and [ __ ] like that
they're just they were like that
yeah like I said there didn't really
seem to be a big delineation between
I kind of feel like that was more like
an 80s thing where there was just like
you know jocks and nerds yeah I didn't
have that back then yeah I think that
was like a different kind of they were
merged into the same Dynamic yeah they
were kind of merged into the same thing
yeah Zach said let's not forget how many
of them are probably autistic too yeah I
think a lot of them uh probably were
and let's see
okay so
um are we ready to like get into this
because I got a few like I got some [ __ ]
we gotta talk about
so uh so this first case what we were
talking about before about the Soviet
Union like covering up a bunch of stuff
uh this guy was one of the first
astronauts he actually died during
training he didn't die in space
but they covered up his death for
several years but it's been Declassified
uh since then so this guy's name is
Valentin bondarenko
and he was a Soviet fighter pilot just
like uh the Americans did they usually
recruited their astronauts or cosmonauts
rather from fighter pilots yeah so he
got selected in 1960 for training so he
was actually chosen to be among the
first group of I think it was only like
18 or 20 people that they chose at first
to be cosmonauts yeah hold on one sec
just like who was at the city there that
they were um autistic attack is that
yeah now Zach I'm going to disagree they
were basically more like jocks back in
those days
listen to how the Soviets recruited
their guys it was pretty much the same
for the United States they were
recruited from fighter pilots and
soldiers and their scientists were kind
of like that too in the weapons
divisions like
um
with my granddad and everything to be be
a contractor McDonald Douglas uh [ __ ]
any of that other [ __ ] you had to be
married
if you weren't married you couldn't work
for them
which I don't think that would fly today
well no because that's kind of against
the law like they can't really
discriminate people that are married or
not back in those days they could and
they're not even really allowed to ask
you that in a job interview the thinking
back then was is that you couldn't be
gay
because if you were gay the Soviets
could get blackmail material on you and
you and you would talk
so being married meant that you weren't
gay therefore you were not subject to
Blackmail
so there was all kinds of security
concerns they wanted [ __ ] that
were All-American apple pie Chevrolet
jocks they were more like jocks than
they were anything else jocks that would
slide rulers
well like I said they wanted people that
didn't really have like skeletons in
themselves I guess that were just kind
of like and um
my great one of the reasons why my
granddad got selected for all that stuff
is because he came from a religious
University
and they they preferred religious people
because they were they could trust them
they really
want anybody from universities that were
left-wing because they were afraid of
communist insurgents so they are
sympathizers so they went for Christians
or Jews
and religious Jews they wanted to
Orthodox Jews uh and they uh
and Mormons
they loved Mormons
because Mormons were evidently patriotic
and real uh trustworthy
they used Mormons insecurity a lot not
so much science but security all the
bodyguards and
private security agencies that [ __ ]
kept people away from [ __ ] tended to be
Mormons and they could do that back then
because it was National Security
so she can go back to the Soviets were
doing a similar thing this is Space Race
[ __ ] and Cold War stuff it was serious
very serious
uh okay so bondarenko was actually the
youngest member of the uh people that
they selected for the Cosmonaut team so
he starts training uh in late May of
1960 for they were planning to launch
this uh vostok spacecraft which was
going to have a crew on it obviously
so what they were doing in preparation
for that uh you know manned spacecraft
mission
was they were doing a 15-day endurance
experiment in like a low pressure
altitude chamber and this was in March
of 1961.
and where they had this I love the name
of this place uh The Institute of
biomedical problems that was in Moscow
so that was where they were doing the
stuff so basically they were like
they're putting you in a low pressure
environment they like I said they want
to see how people are going to like
react to it uh how it's going to be like
up in space
so this Chambers atmosphere was about 50
oxygen
so uh uh so he had been in there like I
said four uh you know several days
and for whatever reason like he kind of
like had knocked off work for the day
he took off they had like biosensors on
there like monitoring all his you know
uh you know vitals and stuff so he takes
them off and then he has like a cotton
ball that had alcohol on it and he just
kind of like washed his skin off like
because you know to get all the glue off
or whatever from the um from the
biosensors
so then he not thinking I guess because
like I said he'd been in there for
several days without incident
um but this alcohol soaked cotton ball
he then like kind of I don't know if he
like chucked it if there was like a
garbage can or and he just missed or I'm
not really sure like what exactly
happened but he throws this
alcohol-soaked cotton ball and it landed
on this electric hot plate
that he had been using to brew tea on so
the cotton ball had alcohol in it like I
said 50 oxygen environment uh low
pressure and it ignited
at which point uh bondarenko tried to
smother the Flames with the sleeve of
his the coveralls that he was wearing
which were made of wool
uh and those caught fire because like I
said oxygen-rich atmosphere
now so he's burning to death in there
and because of the pressure differential
between the inside of the chamber and
the outside uh there was a doctor that
was like watching him but like going oh
my God he's burning to death but he
couldn't get the door open for like half
an hour because of the different like he
you know he couldn't get it open
so uh so basically bondarenko's clothes
burned until uh pretty much all the
oxygen of the chamber was used up and he
had third degree burns pretty much over
his entire body
um so the attending physician basically
said I was trying to like he was still
alive when they finally got him out damn
yeah I'm sure that was third degree
bunch of Oliver's bite yeah
um so they pulled him out and he was
still alive and they were trying to
start an IV drip and the only blood
vessel they could find to put the needle
in were on the bottom of his feet where
his boots were everything else was like
[ __ ] burned and [ __ ] like that
uh so he lived for 16 hours yeah he it's
better that he died yeah I mean Jesus
[ __ ] Christ
so yeah he uh get burned up like that
man you don't really want to live that's
what I mean I mean that would be the
[ __ ] worst because it's not the it's
not like you can recover from that you
know what I mean and from what I've
heard that I mean really like third
degree burns and stuff like that like
that's one of the most painful things
that a human can experience I think at
third you're all the all the nerve
endings are gone at that point but still
it's [ __ ] no you you
you never really recover
that's what I'm saying it was like you
wouldn't you're yeah you're just no you
look too bad you never really get your
normal life back no
but I can't imagine it's like honestly
if that was gonna happen I would rather
just like die immediately just like
laying there like for 16 hours I don't
know I mean I'm sure he was in shock I
don't know if he was like in pain I'm
sure he probably well I'm sure they hit
him up with a bunch of morphine I hope
so Jesus Christ because that's like
[ __ ] horrifying
so in June of 1961 they gave him
posthumously obviously um the order of
the red star but as they did back in the
day back in during the Cold War
uh they did not publish any details
about the accident and about the death
of him now interestingly and this is
something that kind of fueled a lot of
conspiracy theories that came out like
later on because they did do like this
kind of [ __ ] so it's not crazy to think
that they might do it like in other
situations
um because bondarenko had already
appeared in like group films and photos
of the first group of cosmonauts like I
said because he was among like the first
18 20 people that were training as
cosmonauts
um when he died uh they didn't and they
didn't want to say what happened to him
so basically they would take like the
pictures and the pictures and they would
kind of like they'd have Photoshop back
then but you could still kind of erase
people if you were you know if you knew
what you were doing so sometimes they
would like kind of just erase him out of
the photos
uh and they didn't wouldn't tell anybody
like what happened to him so there was
that too
um so basically there was kind of like
uh finally I think it came out at first
in 80 1980 in the west and then in 1986
uh they actually had a Russian writer
that published like a thing about it so
they did actually like admit it finally
uh for a Soviet audience I think like a
western audience got it first like what
had actually happened like in 1980 so
there was that but yeah he got like
airbrushed out of like all the all the
photos and stuff like that which is
[ __ ] crazy
um and I don't know so so like I said
they did do that kind of stuff because
they do have like because I even saw
like pictures of like the original
photograph with him in it and then like
the photograph that they published
subsequently that had him airbrushed out
so they did do that kind of stuff like
to try and because they're like they
didn't even launch him into space but he
[ __ ] died and they didn't really want
anybody knowing about that yeah they did
that with everything so so yeah
um but like I said they did actually
like uh find out about it like in 1980.
so guys that went to prison were also
airbrushed out of everything the Soviets
were Masters at [ __ ] removing you
from the [ __ ] photo yeah there's a
famous one where it's like Stalin with
[ __ ] seven or eight guys walking on
the pier
and he's smiling
and [ __ ] one by one over the years
every one of those guys was [ __ ]
airbrushed out of that photo until it's
eventually just a picture of [ __ ]
style and walking by the walking down
the pier
but I saw an interview with KGB guys
they said that they did that [ __ ] on
purpose because it was a it was a
demonstration of ultimate power
and it made people it like Weekender
racing from history yeah it was the they
did it to make average well to make
Soviet leaders in their Dumont or what
they call their their [ __ ] government
to they lived in fear
they were all controlled by fear even if
in the higher up in the government you
were the more fear they had you under
because they they wouldn't want to need
dissent they did they could erase you
the average person
wasn't in that kind of danger they were
another dangerous but if you were in a
[ __ ] leadership position your ass was
on the [ __ ] line especially when
Stalin was around yeah I'm like people
can erase me from pictures I don't give
a [ __ ] I probably won't even notice but
you know yeah that's the thing but they
erased this guy from photos because he
died during training like in a horrible
way and they didn't really win anybody
to know about it because they're like
well we don't want it to look like our
space program isn't up to Snuff or that
like we [ __ ] something up and even
though I mean honestly it didn't really
have anything to do with the Space
Program per se it was just him kind of
like making a dumb mistake that's all it
was like he just had a cotton ball with
alcohol on it and he threw it and it
landed on a like a hot plate and it just
like ignited so it was just like a freak
accident it didn't really have anything
to do with
you know it not being like the the Space
Program not the like you know what I
mean it wasn't like later on like some
[ __ ] that actually happened in the
United States or happened in the Soviet
Union too where it was actual [ __ ] that
went wrong like with this big spacecraft
it was just like kind of we had a
problem with that high oxygen content in
the in in the cabins later on too I
think there was the Mercury you'll
probably get into that the Mercury
incident remember what Mercury no I
didn't have that on there you'd have it
okay for the three dudes burned up
inside the capsule oh well I have one
like that but it was like it's a Soviet
one oh well the Apollo one you're mean I
thought it was a Mercury no yeah it was
an Apollo that's what yeah that's
actually what I was going to talk about
next that's why I was confused because
I'm like right yeah it's a Mercury
Capsule that's right no no no because it
had three in there yeah that's what
that's what I was just gonna talk about
I carried one because here's the thing
it did I kind of thought these aren't
like and I was gonna put these like in
uh you know uh sequential order like you
know of time and everything but then I
was like ah [ __ ] it so I just like put
stuff in there but they were talking
about
um bondarenko because his death had
occurred like in a you know sealed High
oxygen environment obviously and that's
also what happened to like you you what
we were just talking about like the crew
of the Apollo one like also during kind
of a training Mission now there was
actually later it's not necessarily a
conspiracy theory but there was like
some speculation that oh well maybe if
the Soviets had said like what happened
to
um to bondarenko then NASA would have
been like like oh maybe we should like
look into our you know uh the design of
the Apollo Command Module like maybe
there's some kind of thing that we could
fix there but the thing about it is that
kind of looking back at it they're like
NASA was pretty well aware of that [ __ ]
already so it wasn't like the Soviets
like keeping that from I mean that's
pretty
I kind of feel like oh high oxygen
environment and being like really
flammable I kind of feel like that's
physics 101 you know what I mean they
they would have known about that so I
don't think that it was anything to do
with like the Soviets not telling them
anything like that
um so yeah so now that we're that was a
good segue so now let's actually talk
about the Apollo one thing did they I
think they talked about this when we on
that documentary we were just talking
about it was one of the biggest
tragedies of the U.S space program it
was yeah and this was again like during
a training Mission yeah training and it
was just an accident High oxygen content
inside the capsules yeah I don't know
why they wanted that
you would you think there'd be a way
around that they didn't want to wear
masks
well I think like yeah okay so this is
what happened
um so it happened uh January 27 1967.
and the three astronauts that were
killed were Gus Grissom Ed White and
Roger Chaffee
and this was in the Apollo Command
Module and this was a pre-flight test at
Cape Canaveral which is not that far
from here actually
so they were actually this is like I
said they were training for the first
crude Apollo Fleet and this was going to
be like an Earth orbiting Mission uh and
it was going to be launched on the 21st
of February so that was like a little
bit less than a month before launch now
this was supposed to be a test they
called it a plugs out test and this was
like the Command Module was actually
mounted on the Saturn 1B on the launch
pad
um just like it was going to be for the
actual launch but the Saturn 1B didn't
have any fuel in it but they were just
you know they were doing a mock-up
so they were going to go through the
entire countdown sequence
so the astronauts go into the capsule on
the pad
now a bunch of like little minor
problems kind of cropped up that delayed
the test uh you know while they were you
know trying to do it there were kind of
like failures in communication like they
couldn't like have radio communication
with one another [ __ ] like that
um and Gus Grissom they said actually
made a joke at about 6 30 PM it said how
are we going to get to the moon if we
can't talk between three buildings which
uh you know that's that's a legit
question
uh they also recorded at about a minute
after that there was like a surge
um and they think that was maybe like a
short circuit somewhere
uh and then there's kind of like you
can't really hear exactly what they're
saying like the cop for the cockpit
recording but a couple seconds after
that like after they recorded this what
they presumed was a short circuit one of
the astronauts they're not sure which
one it was says something that sounds
like flames
and then a couple seconds after that
like one of the other ones I believe it
was Ed White said uh we've got a fire in
the cockpit and the fire actually spread
through the cabin like just in a couple
of seconds I mean it was very very quick
uh then Chaffee says we have a bad fire
and then there's like there then they
all start yelling
so basically the communication ended
about 17 seconds after uh you know
whoever the first person was that said
something about fire or Flames or
whatever uh and then they lost all the
all communication like all Telemetry or
whatever now the thing about the Apollo
hatch uh It could only open inward and
it was uh it was held closed by like a
bunch of latches uh that were operated
by ratchets
and it was also held closed by interior
pressure which was the pressure inside
was higher than the pressure outside uh
so you had to like vent The Command
Module before the hatch could be opened
and it took about 90 seconds uh to do
that like under uh you know ideal
conditions which obviously these were
not
so because the cabin had been filled
with a pure oxygen atmosphere at normal
pressure for the test there had been a
whole bunch of uh a really long time for
the oxygen to permeate all the material
in the cabin
um the fire spread very very quickly and
the astronauts had absolutely no time to
get the hatchet but it had just happened
too quickly it was just like like the
fire were they in suits pressure suits
um I you know what I don't think they
were because for a long time because
you'll see that happen with the
Challenger thing too and they've changed
it now subsequently I believe but for a
long time these like during launch and
stuff like that they didn't wear the
suits yeah I think they do now though
yeah because all they had to do is just
shut their visors yeah during that fire
yeah they'd have been saved
is that suit can that suit can handle a
lot of heat right especially for that
short period of time
that's the thing I think for a long time
even up until the 80s I think they
didn't even wear the suits like when
they were like launching and stuff which
seems in hindsight that seems kind of
like inadvisable like probably because
you just shut the visor it's got its own
you could you could have it hooked up to
its own oxygen
you know you wouldn't even need oxygen
in in the case of a fire could be enough
oxygen in the suit to get you through
those few minutes
while the fire was burned right you know
but I guess they just weren't thinking
about I never would have been [ __ ]
around pure oxygen anyway
I don't understand why what what were
they testing
pure oxygen is highly flammable well
yeah obviously it's like saying this
flood the place with [ __ ] gasoline
yeah it'll be all right
be more likely to [ __ ] vacate the
oxygen make it all nitrous and nitrogen
something real inert well now they do
like nitrogen oxygen yeah like a mixture
I'd flood that whole [ __ ] with
nitrogen through the whole launch and
just breathe oxygen through a mask
in the suit
you know no chance of a fight like I
said you're not getting my ass in there
anyway right but if you did get my ass
in there I'm like I want all the suits I
want like [ __ ] I want a suit I want
like a [ __ ] uh I I just want all the
stuff like on top of everything for you
people that have don't have any idea
what we're talking about we're talking
about any of these Apollo Rockets
when you see real footage of what it's
like to go into the [ __ ]
Command Module of an Apollo Rocket and
what's that what that's actually like
it's like being at a ride at Disneyland
on top of [ __ ] rickety skyscraper
blowing in the wind and stepping across
this thing and getting into this damn
flimsy aluminum cigar
that's blowing in the wind like a
[ __ ] Spike and it's filled with
[ __ ] rocket fuel
it's a bomb you're riding on a bomb
basically just like in doctor strange
it's just a slowly yeah yeah it's just
the explosion is a controlled explosion
but [ __ ] if you see that the bottom
of that Saturn rocket going on going off
it's like an earthquake it's a [ __ ]
bomb
the controlled explosion
and you're in it I hell wouldn't want
any goddamn oxygen in the cabin I'd give
me an oxygen mask I'm inside the suit
inside the cabin you know flood the
cabin with nitrogen
that way because you see you can pull
the Command Module
had an emergency kind of an inject
system
it had a Spire that came out of the top
of it with three or four [ __ ] rocket
nozzles vectored off like that so if
anything bad happened if if the rocket
started to explode they could hit
basically an eject button and the
rockets would pull the [ __ ] Command
Module off the top of the Saturn rocket
and it would fly off in another
Direction and then it had parachutes
you know yeah would that have actually
worked
well probably better than sister to
death better better than sitting there
burning or having that thing blow it up
I mean at least you'd have a chance yeah
better than what they had here yeah and
they probably had some backup
systems like some circuits down inside
the other stages so if it detected an
explosion it probably would
electronically automatically hit the
eject for you it's probably how that
worked because they had the technology
for that kind of stuff back then I would
trust the pilots to do it
astronaut wouldn't have the reflex
well that's why like I said I kind of
feel like nowadays they um a lot of [ __ ]
is controlled from the ground yeah uh
you know and a lot of stuff is automatic
you know a computer like nowadays but
like I said it took them a long time I
mean
considering some of the crazy [ __ ] that
they did when they were trying to figure
out how to get this [ __ ] to work I'm
amazed that they didn't lose more people
you know it's horrible like the ones
that they did lose in it like in
horrible ways but I'm actually surprised
more people didn't die before drawer
down said yeah I'd just stand on the
ground and watch somebody else do it
yeah that's right that's exactly yeah
yeah that's what I mean you wouldn't get
my ass in there it's like I'm sorry I'm
not going to space not I'm just not in
those early astronauts man they were
like [ __ ] gladiators
before they put those fighter pilots in
there
one of the original ideas was to put
prisoners in there
that's how dangerous it was well that's
what I'm saying yeah in a way it's just
kind of like
at least nobody would feel bad then
probably yeah it would still because I
mean put some serial killers in there
put some BTK yeah let's say let's send
BTK into space
those astronauts had to go through hell
during that training they'd sit there
and spin them on a centrifuge and give
they'd have to keep their bearings
they'd spin them on four different
accesses and they had to use controls to
see if they could stop the spin and work
you know what I mean because that those
capsule could be [ __ ] in space
tumbling like crazy
you know and zero g well that's the
whole thing they're trying to train them
for every contingency and they want
people that aren't gonna like freak out
yeah if like [ __ ] starts going sideways
they need somebody that's like Gonna
Keep Their cool and most people can't I
mean that's why it's that's why it's so
difficult to become an astronaut even
nowadays when shit's like a lot easier
or more automated but back then they
were just kind of like a lot of people
like didn't make it no just just by
they'd take a dude they put him in a
centers fuge for an hour and just spin
him in random directions if you got sick
you couldn't be an artist or not yeah
they said some dudes were so [ __ ] a
newer to it that they could sleep in it
that may be [ __ ] crazy huh you gotta
and you gotta just totally ignore your
equilibrium
I can't imagine I've been seasick before
I couldn't imagine just being spun and
spun in three different accesses you
know [ __ ] I get dizzy just walking down
the hall to the bathroom so I can't even
imagine
spinning you for an hour and dude's in
there [ __ ] sleeping
maybe well the thing about it is that
maybe if you're asleep maybe that's
better because you're like not
concentrating you're not thinking about
it
but that's the thing there is kind of
like a physical component too because
it's like you're [ __ ] it's [ __ ] up
all your inner ear like [ __ ] and
everything like that so I imagine that
has to be like a very very rare
individual that can override that
because that's that evolved for a reason
you know I've I've gotten [ __ ]
terribly seasick before
you know out there in Rough Waters on
the [ __ ] Gulf of Mexico yeah
you can handle it for two hours but hour
three all of a sudden you're just
[ __ ] throwing up
you know
and then then it goes away eventually
now you didn't you know after like four
hours into it then all of a sudden
you're you're now immune to it well yeah
you get used to it yeah so you you know
like humans are very adaptable yeah but
I've never been on a boat long enough to
get I've never gotten seasick
I've been on a lot of boats in my life
but I don't think I've ever gotten
seasick but man I mean the thing about
it though is that up and down well yeah
but it's like even it's weird because I
can go on like roller coasters and [ __ ]
like that I don't get motion sickness or
anything like that it takes time but
sometimes
um like if I'm watching a movie like if
it's in 3D and there's like a lot of
[ __ ] where people are like flying around
or on top of a building or something
like that I will get kind of like
nauseous I don't throw up or anything
like that but it does make me like kind
of dizzy and uh it only gets me in
storms and it's gotten me twice in
storms yeah
just you know [ __ ] 14 foot waves just
constantly up and down and up and down
and it depends on which direction the
[ __ ] ship's going or the boat's going
you can follow the waves and all of a
sudden you're down in the bottom of it
just riding along with the wave you
never grasp it it feels like it's dead
yeah
then you go into the waves and it's
terrible yeah
no thanks yeah no thanks like I said I
don't you know my ears are [ __ ] up
enough as it is so I don't need any more
of that it's [ __ ] stress
but yeah so uh so where was I okay so
um
like I said like so oxygen permeated
everything in the uh you know in the
capsule and obviously like the
technicians that were standing nearby
like they knew what was going on in
there and they were trying to like open
the doors to like get the people out but
like obviously by then it was like too
late and it was too hot they couldn't
like get in there anyway
um they did actually get the hatch open
after five minutes but obviously that
was way too late uh they think that the
astronauts uh already died probably
within the first 30 seconds because of
smoke inhalation and burns and
everything like that because like I said
it just went it just went up like that
so the Apollo program actually got put
on hold
while they were doing the investigation
of the accident obviously they figured
uh they're not 100 sure but they're like
the most likely scenario was that there
was a short circuit uh that and it kind
of made a spark that ignited and it was
in a bundle of wires that was
um like in front of Gus grissom's seat
and because a lot of the stuff like the
material in the capsule was you know
super flammable and was kind of soaked
in oxygen
um you know the fire obviously just like
lit and spread like really quickly and
there really wasn't anything that
anybody could do about it so because of
this accident
they um you know they did a bunch of
like changes in the program like
obviously yeah get rid of that damn
oxygen well yeah and so they designed a
new hatch which is one of the things
that you could open from uh outward and
could be operated like really really
quickly they took a bunch of the
flammable material out of the capsule
which you know that's that's a good idea
and uh they also replaced it with like a
like flame retardant or stuff that would
like self-extinguish uh they also
started using a nitrogen oxygen mix at
launch instead of pure oxygen which like
I said seems like a good idea and uh
yeah that's what I'm saying well
took three people to die before they
were just like oh maybe that was stupid
maybe I want to know what the pro what
the thinking was
I'm not really I mean I'm sure they had
their reasons they had a reason they
want let's go with pure oxygen that's
like saying let's let's flood the place
with gasoline
what were they thinking we want to make
sure that they got plenty of air
to breathe in case the [ __ ] something
breaks
like the [ __ ] air scrubbers break
yeah maybe that's what it was but like I
said didn't anybody say hey guys like I
swear it's also like super yeah
give them [ __ ] [ __ ] air tank I
mean seriously like you just have like
one little spark and just it just goes
up like a [ __ ] room a candle so you
know I know weight was an issue maybe
they were just trying to keep something
real light
that too that's kind of like another
thing that they're yeah but that I don't
know man it's like I don't really know
that like I said that seems like a
really obvious but maybe it only seems
obvious to us in hindsight I don't know
what they were thinking I'm like I said
I'm sure they had a reason
but then after this happened these four
three these three poor [ __ ]
that had to die for that to happen yeah
like
I don't know at least they didn't die in
vain I guess because them dying was just
like oh we need to fix this that and the
other thing and then he died invade but
they died at the hand so [ __ ] bad
designer weld that too an engineer
wasn't thinking right so that team
wasn't thinking right somebody's heads
should have rolled for that
maybe it did I mean I I kind of hope it
did it's a bad decision but I mean the
changes that they made I mean the Apollo
program you know largely very successful
other than the mishap with Apollo 13 but
you know when it came to the look man
the 50s the 60s even the 70s when I was
a kid it was a wild times safety was not
a [ __ ]
big concern especially in [ __ ] like
Motor Sports and sports but this was not
Sports man this was [ __ ] science all
right this was [ __ ] this is the space
race
they were supposed to be safety
conscious
you know they were professional so I
don't understand the oversight these are
smart guys I don't know what they were
thinking
there was some reason but
their thinking wasn't right
probably had something to do with
keeping weight down
for some kind of a [ __ ] oxygen
delivery system in the in the capsule
for some reason it was something like
that
had to there was some kind of reason
Hugo said astronauts that can keep their
cool like Neil Armstrong when he landed
the lunar module they almost crashed
yeah I'm I mean some of those astronauts
are like supernaturally
calm well they were selected for that
that's what I mean that's why it's so
difficult like to become because they
really need like the cream of the crop
that really are not gonna like seriously
you really have to like keep your [ __ ]
together even when the worst [ __ ] is
happening you guys are pointing out good
[ __ ] and Jenny's [ __ ] expounded on
some good [ __ ] this is why I get so
upset with the state of the [ __ ] US
Army and their combat food you can't
just get random [ __ ] and put
them in a damn combat unit
it
you can but they fail and you're killing
them when you do that
elite units have to be hand-picked
they're hand-picked monkeys there's only
some guys that are good at that well
people are good at different things
right yeah and it's like it's better if
you pick people that are really yeah I
mean it's you know it's much less likely
that they'll die if they can like keep
their [ __ ] again like and being an
astronaut less so nowadays than it was
back then yeah but back then it was very
very dangerous because it was very new
it was still dangerous now because I'm
not saying it's not dangerous but it was
a lot more when I was in service being
[ __ ] SF or sfd there's Delta or Delta
or anything like that even Army Rangers
those guys were like pro ball players
I tried I couldn't get into the Rangers
[ __ ] but neither can any of my
friends
you know it was not there's no disgrace
to to get [ __ ] Zapped during [ __ ]
pre-rip you know what I mean just the
way it was
because we were all good but they only
took
into getting Special Forces man you had
to be [ __ ] special now anybody can do
it
it's just it's a waste very dangerous
before throw down said we're the
astronauts breathing this stuff I
thought pure oxygen made people high
that's another thing too I kind of feel
like
yeah were they
I think they were
I think they were breathing it that
seems like not the best idea they
probably aren't breathing very deeply it
might have been part of their relations
breathe really shallow you guys well it
might have been part of their oxygen
delivery system yeah to have a very very
oxygen rich cabin
and just breathe very low
because you know they did in hospitals
yeah that's true that's true
there was there was some thinking behind
it
yeah like I said they weren't dumb and
like they you know I'm sure they had
some kind of reason but yeah I mean
obviously that uh didn't work out the
way they might have been some kind of
oxygen scrubber that was [ __ ]
scrubbing the [ __ ] cabin oxygen over
and over again and it was just their Air
Supply it was being recycled somehow it
might have been something like that
so it's best to start it off with real
pure oxygen because eight hours later it
wasn't as good you know what I mean that
kind of thing or you might be the last
five days on the damn same oxygen
because they're all in a capsule and
they're capturing it's like it's oxygen
there's all kind of like fart air
there's all kind of like stuff going on
in there no it's gross they didn't have
foreign I'm just joking
far there they would the diets are just
like in the Army everything's [ __ ]
highly selected for [ __ ] not having
farts and not having to go to the
bathroom very often yeah see they've
they thought of it and not for needing
even you don't even need toilet paper
just comes out in like a [ __ ] greasy
brick gross yeah yeah
yeah
they know exactly what they're doing
well like I said they have all and
there's they have like specialists in
their whole specialty is you know
picking the dye pooping in a spacesuit
yeah like you know MREs are astronauts
food that's where that technology came
from it's ready to go and [ __ ] the
most beautiful thing about MREs and
astronaut food it all worked out for the
Army is that it was good no matter what
temperature it was we were eating that
[ __ ] Frozen [ __ ] solid in Korea but a
block and it still tasted good tuna and
noodles frozen like slush just would
just be beautiful tuna noodle popsicles
yeah well I [ __ ]
challenge you I tried it go get you one
of them Dinty more
instant meals that's kind of like an MRE
go [ __ ] freeze that thing or eat at
room temperature especially the ones
that have a cream flavor you won't be
able to eat it tastes like [ __ ]
it has to be hot for it to taste good
MRE could be frozen block and it'd be
delicious
was that just your perception though
because no no they tasted good okay
everybody loved it I'm just asking
because then it ends up being kind of
like Japanese food or something you know
we'd be eating a [ __ ] frozen ham
slice and it would be cracking and
popping while you're eating it you're
like yeah man it's kind of like Eskimo
whale blubber it says yeah it's good it
doesn't tastes well no see I can see how
that would be good like a frozen ham
slice yeah yeah it was really good that
would be probably the frozen chicken a
la king it was good
yeah that's not hey I eat cold Fried
Chickens yeah that can't be that weird
that was nice but that's because they
selected that menu for all weather
they didn't give you anything that
didn't taste good that Frozen you know
what they're doing and none of it makes
any gas
they know because you're gonna be packed
inside armored vehicles that's what I
mean it's like nobody should be like 30
dudes in the back man come on 30 dudes
piled up just stacked
stack all right in the back of a [ __ ]
five ton truck it's 40 degrees below
zero all trying to survive from just one
body heat alone all right there can't be
any gas yeah you don't want to be
farting in your face right yeah yeah
yeah
it's something that you have to consider
even though you don't like to think
about it but yeah like some people have
thought about it it's the whole thing
yeah they're trying to make your life as
yeah I mean you know it's you don't want
it to be like completely miserable like
I said I don't want to be stacked up
with a bunch of dudes that are just like
farting in my face all day long
Jeff yard said I think we take for
granted how much planning goes into
exploring a new frontier getting to the
Moon is likely far more difficult than
we realize yes it is yes yes even by
today's standards of scientific
development everything is much harder
than
uh then I think most people realize yeah
and I think I mean it's easier nowadays
it's still difficult but it was much
more difficult back then because they
didn't have computers they didn't have
the [ __ ] that we have nowadays so even
though it's difficult nowadays I kind of
feel like it was much harder back then
because you had to do everything like
Analog Man yeah but they just used more
guys
and they thought about it and talked
about it more
they had pow wows and they talked about
it and would theorized and write it out
and draw it out on a napkin and Drake
you know and it worked it worked that
way because they they took their time
and everything was handcrafted
some of the accidents have happened
recently with all this space [ __ ]
because people not converting [ __ ]
from metric into English or American
Standard in the in the metric and weird
data oversights
well there's so much because there's so
much [ __ ] yeah they're all automated to
consider that it's like it's easy to
override like one little thing back in
those days it was all just Hands-On
human stuff and they had different teams
all talking with each other each one
with their own specialty but even then
then they still [ __ ] up yeah but they
got good at it yeah some of that [ __ ]
was imagination
like on the bottom of the [ __ ] the
rocket that we're talking about here the
nozzle on on the on the bottom of the
[ __ ] um
Apollo [ __ ] heavy lift booster
they were looking at the spray nozzles
spraying the the fuel inside the
combustion Chambers and [ __ ]
on the outside of the damn rocket
and they were
using theories you know theorems and
mathematical stuff to try to figure out
how much thrust that was producing
and they're looking at it and there was
a guy that was just really good
saying you could get a whole lot more
thrust if you just put a little piece of
metal right here to [ __ ] disturb the
Eddies coming off of this side and it'll
[ __ ] cause it and the dude totally
predicted it they got more thrust just
by adding a little piece of metal so the
spray nozzle wouldn't spray such a
perfect jet of fuel
because he could imagine how it would
actually happen and that can how it
would be burning in there
and how to
get more thrust
and a computer probably couldn't have
imagined that but he could
so humans are good at certain things
to do is just a combustion engineer
yeah some humans are good some humans
yeah he's like a Rembrandt you know he
could have Envision it in his head
that's how
that's how [ __ ] uh Albert Einstein
did you know all of his work he was he
he imagined it
imagine what it would be like
approaching the speed of light
relatively relativity was all
imagination and then he proved it with
math not the other way around he didn't
come up with some math that showed him
relativity
he imagined relativity and proved it
mathematically yeah but most people's
brains don't work that way like he was
actually quite exceptional in that
regard but guys in NASA could do that
right because that's what they where
they were they were selected for that
yeah so in some ways they're in some
ways they were better than super
computers some of them a lot of them
Mark says 100 oxygen doesn't get you
high per se if your blood oxygen is low
it will help make you more alert the
explosion probably affected the
pressurized O2 tanks yeah I mean
like I said I'm not really sure I'm sure
they had reasons for it being like that
but
the fact that that had to happen like
before they changed it was like kind of
a shame but you know
that's just kind of what happened
all right so the next one I want to talk
about this is another Soviet one and
this one is this is kind of [ __ ] up
and we didn't like find this out until
later on because this was another one
that they kind of covered up at the time
like during the Cold War
but then uh the reality of it came out
like later on
so this is a guy named Vladimir komarov
now he was another Soviet Cosmonaut one
of the uh you know initial ones that was
chosen to train as a cosmonaut like in
the early days
uh but he would actually become famous
sadly
as the man who fell from space which is
pretty [ __ ] up oh okay I know what
you're talking about yeah
so 1967
um it was the 50th gonna be the 50th
anniversary of the Communist Revolution
so they wanted to do like some big
historic space mission to like
commemorate that
so they chose Vladimir komarov for this
Mission uh and the spoiler alert it
didn't like work out so well
now he was a very well-trained Cosmonaut
uh but the mission that they sent him on
which was called the soyuz soyuz uh one
yeah was
um
maybe kind of like rushed because they
were trying to get it you know going in
in
you know in time
well that too but they were kind of like
they they also wanted it like in time
for like the the commemoration of the uh
Communist Revolution like anniversary or
whatever
um now there were rumors but I don't
know if this is true because a lot of
this stuff came out like in this book
from 2011 which is called Starman
uh which was about this this whole
situation
but some of the stuff in there has been
disputed like some people said yeah
that's not really what happened and
stuff like that but the story goes that
before the [ __ ] was even launched that
every like a bunch of people knew that
there were like all kinds of like
structural problems like before this
spacecraft even took off and that some
engineers and stuff like that like try
to inform like some high-ranking Soviets
uh you know saying hey we really don't
want to launch this because there's all
kind of problems and they were
deliberately ignored
um I don't know how how true that is
obviously there was something wrong with
it because uh as we'll see
but I don't know if it was quite as
egregious as uh this book kind of makes
it seem
so
um you know I I don't know I just kind
of feel like this guy's death it's like
it is still kind of mysterious but I
think it's been exaggerated a little bit
now what ended up happening was that
komarov actually
so he goes up in the spacecraft that was
fine he makes a bunch of orbits around
the Earth in the spacecraft
now when it was time for him to come
back like do re-entry
uh he couldn't really do it like he kept
like not working out
and uh so he had it it ended up he
couldn't like re-enter like the way he
wanted to and he had to like go back
around the earth like a couple of times
and it ended up like not so good so the
thing about him he started out
um
by the way if you Google his name
Vladimir komarov
there's a very very famous picture of
what was left of him when he came back
to earth oh I didn't see about it I
didn't see that oh man after the impact
what did it look like
it doesn't look like a purse was it
burned
yeah oh okay yeah yeah
it's basically like a picture of like
two officials looking at looking at a
little a lump of yeah it looks like a
little bird
if nobody told you that was a person you
would not know I remember that was a
person
this is the guy that was talking the
whole way down
talking to his wife now okay that's a
different one okay I got him confused
yeah that's that's it there was another
Soviet guy that talked his whole way
down talking to his wife
is sad you're gonna cover him no no I
don't know because it's not much of a
mystery
but um shoot didn't deploy
well no I mean that's what happened with
this guy but yeah well
okay we'll get into that the other guy's
shoot didn't deploy and he says look the
shoot didn't deploy and he says well he
says I'm gonna go out the capsule and
[ __ ] get it and try to deploy it and
you're like nah don't bother
and he's like no I should do it he goes
we'll get your wife on the line this and
that and he talked to his wife the whole
way down
I think I would have said [ __ ] that [ __ ]
and [ __ ] throwing the cat the capsule
door open
and tried to deploy the shoot but he
might have been coming down at High mock
anyway
so he's probably coming down to [ __ ]
mock [ __ ] seven you know so you
wouldn't be able to hold on you'd just
be [ __ ] gone
that's the only thing I'm thinking go
ahead yeah but I didn't find that case
but yeah yeah I mean it's similar to
this but well I mean it didn't come up
in anything that I looked at he didn't
burn up though he was just smashed flat
on impact no this guy was uh burned up
and like I said there's photos of what
was left when it came back which is like
I said if nobody told you that was a
person you would not know that was a
person I remember seeing the photo it's
black and white yeah
um so yeah so this guy actually he
joined he actually joined the Soviet Air
Force when he was just 15 and uh he was
a pilot by the time 1949 rolled around
10 years later he uh graduated from the
Air Force engineering Academy and he
wanted to become a cosmonaut and like
the first guy that we talked about who
died in the you know the accident in the
training uh he was actually one of the
first you know 18 20 guys that were
selected to be cosmonauts now he um
actually the first thing that he did
to distinguish himself and this is one
of the reasons that he was picked for
this big mission
was that he piloted um something called
vascad vascad one which was the first
vessel to carry more than one person
into space
uh he actually wasn't the first man in
space obviously that was uh Yuri Gagarin
uh but he was you know kind of like a
very well-known like very famous in the
Soviet Union
so he gets to be like sent out on this
famous mission
so what this mission was going to be
that was commemorating the 50th
anniversary of the
whatever of the Communist Revolution
what they were going to do was they were
going to have two space two space
capsules we're gonna Rendezvous in low
earth orbit and um komarov was gonna
like Park one capsule next to the other
one and then spacewalk between the two
of them that was going to be like the
big thing that we was gonna do
now according to the book star man which
like I said came out in 2011 and it's
about this and it came out and like
everybody kind of like freaked out about
it but then like some people came in and
kind of like fact check it and said some
of the stuff was kind of like
exaggerated
but what it said in the book was that
his spacecraft had
203 structural problems that's very
specific
um and that they these were all evident
before it took off
now they're not disputing that the
spacecraft had uh issues obviously it
did but 2 203 they're not sure if that's
the actual number or not now
um Yuri Gagarin was supposedly comorov's
backup pilot
and Gagarin allegedly
um said that the mission should be
postponed because there were too many
problems with the spacecraft and
supposedly allegedly Gagarin also wrote
a 10-page memo and gave it to a friend
of his who was in the KGB said hey
please stop the mission because
um there's all kind of [ __ ] wrong with
this spacecraft but then like the memo
was ignored and the [ __ ] went ahead
anyway now nobody knows that this memo
actually exists or if this was just a
story or whatever
um none of the stuff like people's
Memoirs or like official accounts that
came out later on that were Declassified
ever said that the memo existed so they
don't really know if they really existed
or not
so um basically it's just kind of like
they really wanted this to go ahead
though because this was going to be like
a really big deal and so it's possible
that this whole entire mission was
rushed maybe before the [ __ ] was you
know uh ready for prime time let's call
it that
now
um the thing about it like in the book
They're basically like komarov
knew that he was gonna die or like
suspected that he was gonna die on this
mission
and but because he knew that Gagarin was
his backup he's like no I'm gonna go
because I don't want my friend Yuri
Gagarin to die like I said that's
probably an exaggeration also but that's
what the book put forward
um and the thing about it is that Yuri
Gagarin having been the first man in
space
uh the Soviets were not about to
actually send him on this [ __ ]
mission because they're like he's he was
the first man in space he's a national
hero they're like yeah we probably
they're like they probably just made him
the backup astronaut just at like in
name only they're like they wouldn't
have sent him back into space they're
like we don't want him to get killed for
Christ's sake gregaron was a huge PR
victory for the [ __ ] Soviet Union
that's what I'm saying pictures of that
[ __ ] were all over the United
States and he was just a good looking
little stocky Russian dude and who had a
charming smile and was just uh
you know that he he he was a Soviet
superhero the girls liked him he was he
was he was the man
that's what I'm saying so I kind of feel
like the Soviets wouldn't have I'm not
saying that they didn't say yeah Yuri
garen's the backup on this Mission but I
don't think like if komarov had backed
out they'd been like yeah gagarin's not
going
it's like we're not gonna risk him
having him get killed if this [ __ ] goes
sideways because he was like you said he
was like a huge PR
yeah the whole world the whole world
loved him really sure even Americans
liked him they were they were impressed
he was plain spoken
kind of Russian peasant stock
kind of a war hero type dude and uh was
just big contagious smile and yeah it's
gonna be okay you're real positive you
know
so he he uh was helping put the Soviet
Empire's best foot forward now let's
listen to me okay people
I'm a product of the Cold War
I was [ __ ] raised in a Christian
Military Academy [ __ ] family all
[ __ ] government
servants back when our government was
trying to do the right thing if you
asked me I don't like communism at all
because it's totalitarian it won't work
if it's not too authalitarian
but don't for one second think that the
[ __ ] Russians and the Soviet people
didn't have balls they had a lot of
balls a lot of talent
they're good people you know
just didn't I didn't agree with their
system nobody did
back in those days America could deliver
greater wealth
greater opportunity
that's all I'm gonna say about it so I
don't discount the Soviet effort
the Soviet effort was [ __ ] always
high
you know they were doing a lot with
little they didn't have a lot but they
did a lot with it they had a lot of
talent
I mean they beat us into space that's
for sure yeah they had a lot of talent
talent and guts they weren't stupid
Zach says I just Googled Yuri Gagarin
goddamn talk about a thousand Watts mile
yeah yeah yeah so that's why I'm
thinking I think it's unlikely that they
would have risked his ass on this
particular Mission I'm not saying that
like they knew that this mission was
gonna fail I'm just saying that I don't
think that they necessarily would have
sent Yuri Gagarin if the other guy
didn't go that's all I'm saying
so April 23 1967 they sent Comer off uh
up in his spacecraft
now it was 24 hours and he orbited the
Earth 16 times
and then he was kind of supposed to like
um he had like two solar panels on the
uh on the thing that were supposed to
you know give the energy for the whole
like uh re-entry kind of thing one of
them didn't deploy
so basically the service like we'll just
you know come on back like right now
it's kind of like early or whatever
uh so he starts to do that
but what happened was that he's starting
to do like he tried to do re-entry but
he had trouble uh firing like the the
rocket breaks the thing that was like
supposed to slow him down like to come
back into re-entry
and so he couldn't really do it so he
circled the Earth two more times
and then started to do the re-entry
protocol
now he comes in at an altitude of 23 000
feet and the parachute That was supposed
to deploy
didn't deploy
uh as it turned out while he was you
know he when he tried to re-enter before
and then he had to go around like the um
I guess like the lines of the shoot got
tangled and so it wouldn't like pop out
so what ended up happening was that
April 24th 1967 he plummeted to the
ground and was killed in a in an
explosion he was actually the first man
to die in space flight now interestingly
and maybe this is I don't know if this
is
um what you were talking about earlier
but there are urban legends that he said
like a bunch of [ __ ] like while he was
coming down because he knew he was gonna
die right because he was just like
coming down to earth and he had like
some time
in the book which came out in 2011
it said that komarov was like really
really angry like when he was coming
down and he kept saying stuff like this
devil ship nothing I Lay My Hands On
works properly
um and started like cursing the people
that sent him on the ship like knowing
that it was [ __ ] up and it's like
knowing that he wasn't gonna come back
however
um I have actually seen the transcript
of what he actually said like on the way
back down and apparently he didn't seem
to think there was any problem until
there was you know what I mean because
he was just saying regular [ __ ] like he
just said regular [ __ ]
um and basically he's like oh I'm
feeling excellent like everything like
separation complete or something like
that and then like they lost
transmission and that's it so I don't
think he said all of that stuff about
like the devil ship and anything like
that and most of the people that have
kind of like looked into it that are
actually like test pilots and astronauts
themselves they're like that's not some
[ __ ] that an astronaut would do like
they usually like keep their cool under
those situations
um you know what I mean like he was a
very experienced Cosmonaut and he had
training as a you know he was an Air
Force officer he was a tech pilot and
they're like they're kind of trained for
this kind of stuff so to think that he
just like went off the rails and was
like raging at the entire world like
seems that's a different guy than when I
was talking about the other one was kind
of resigned to his fate he wanted to go
outside and fix the chute
and they told him not to so uh they put
him on with his wife he talked to his
wife all the way down until impact
I didn't yeah yeah there was another one
that went down and finally went down
like that I didn't find that then they
showed the capsule I saw the picture of
the capsule it's in the center of a
[ __ ] crater out in the middle of a
[ __ ] Russian Field
it was sad now I did see a picture of
this capsule as well which was out in
the middle of a field as well yeah but
they all end up like that well yeah
Russia was a bunch of fields yeah
but I mean so nobody knows what exactly
he said on the way down but like I said
I saw the transcript of what he what
they think he actually said and it was
just like normal [ __ ] it wasn't he
wasn't like yelling at anybody or
anything Zach if you think [ __ ] Yuri
Gagarin [ __ ] had a great smile and
was cute I know how y'all you and them
Jewish boys
when I got out of the Army and went up
to [ __ ] Boston I was hanging out
[ __ ] Man Ray and fell in with an X
this ex-russian infantry guy he was the
same age as me his name was uh Vadim
conyev and and [ __ ] me and him were
[ __ ] peas in a pot
both have an infantry background but he
was Soviet infantry so we [ __ ] talk
all kinds of stories he was the
Russian Jewish
Antonio Banderas he had [ __ ] long
black hair I showed pictures of him to
Jenny he's like man he's cute
he was very popular me and him [ __ ]
did very well you liked him
oh that I didn't know if you were to say
something no I'm telling Zach yeah he
likes some Jewish guys he [ __ ] he
liked Vadim
but yeah so this guy they did recover
his remains and as I said uh if you
Google his name you will see the very
famous picture of uh his Remains The
Story Goes that the only thing that was
still recognizable as human was like his
heel bone
so you know there's that which is like
pretty horrifying and like I said they
still
refer to him as the man who fell from
space damn which is [ __ ] up that's
[ __ ] up
so and like I said this was another one
that was kind of I don't know if this
one was as covered up as the other
accident but it was still like covered
up until like a little bit later on now
here's another one that was also kind of
you talking about the man who fell from
space there's been several and there's
another one it's not gonna be in this
they had another dude I think it was
American they put him in a spacesuit
they had him on a little platform and
had these balloons that took him [ __ ]
so high up he was almost in space and
he's on he was sitting oh I remember I
remember yeah and then he jumped off
he jumped off and I think he was in a
space suit with a parachute that was
wild and they have it recorded
he didn't die though no he did you know
he lived yeah he lived but they recorded
the whole thing I don't remember what it
was for it was some kind of a scientific
experiment
yeah I remember like we saw um we saw
footage of that it was wild yeah and I
was like yeah no thank you
imagine being on that platform he was on
that ship for hours as it was well like
I said they showed it like showed the
[ __ ] yeah because they they taped it
like the whole thing and I was just like
oh no yeah I I was [ __ ] just [ __ ]
watching him sit on that down that's
what I'm saying I can't watch He's damn
near in space that's strong he's [ __ ]
out too much yeah and he got up looking
on the platform just jumped off [ __ ] I
don't even like to get on a chair to
like reach some highest [ __ ] on a shelf
I get nervous doing that much less it's
like hey let's go a couple miles above
the Earth like on a little platform yeah
no thanks no thanks not only flying a
plane either that's I mean I've done it
but I don't I don't like it Danny seeing
I'm looking like the [ __ ] former WCW
wrestler Perry Saturn with the facial
hair
we'll see I don't know who that is I
don't know who that is either I don't I
don't I don't watch wrestling wrestling
I'm becoming a wrestler wrestling yeah
yeah you need a wrestling name yeah
maybe you should get like a luchadorian
mask well I have one oh that's right you
do yeah what happened to it it's over
there it's in my other room oh okay
that's right I forgot that you had yeah
it's uh Bane it's a bane
I freaking totally forgot all about that
I'd wear it more often to the club but
you can't drink through it because the
mouse club yeah because you gotta keep
it I gotta take it out which which you
know I'm gonna get a real Mexican
Luchador mask because those have exposed
mouths they look like something out of a
damn BDSM [ __ ] show yeah you need
like [ __ ] mask yeah it's like a gift man
like a zipper yeah with a zipper so you
could unzip it and then drink and that's
it
but yeah so here's another uh Soviet one
that was covered up for a long time
and I think that you might have referred
to this one earlier this is the crew of
the soyuz 11.
now this was actually the only crude
mission to board the world's first space
station which was called the solute one
so there were three guys in the crew
Georgie and I'm sure I'm gonna pronounce
these horrible names wrong
um dabrov dabra volski
volski yeah uh vatislav volkov and
Victor potsayev
so they come they get to the space
station uh in early June of 1971 and
they were there for like almost a month
what ended up happening okay
so the spacecraft was launched uh on the
6th of June 1971. and they had launched
one before like soy is 10 That was
supposed to dock with the space station
but they [ __ ] it up and they didn't
like nobody died or anything like that
but um it didn't dock successfully and
they just came back
so
um so they sent soyuz 11. now they went
and docked with the space station uh
they said it took over three hours like
three hours 20 minutes something like
that
to do the docking maneuver in uh early
June of 1971. now the cosmonauts the
three cosmonauts whose names I just
mentioned uh were on board the space
station for 22 days and which actually
was a record until the uh Skylab 2
mission in 1973. it's good because that
was like the longest time that anybody
had been in space
so they come into the space station
there was kind of like you know smoke
and burning and [ __ ] like that there was
some fires while they were there but
everything was fine like everything was
sorted out they did like some live TV
broadcasts while they were on there
because like I said they were on there
for almost a month and it was like
supposedly like this big successful
mission right
now
um so the 29th of June 1971. they were
gonna get back into the capsule and they
were gonna leave the space station and
come back to earth hopefully
um so they take all the stuff they took
a lot of films and like scientific
specimens and tapes and all their gear
and [ __ ] like that and they put it back
in soyuz 11 their little spacecraft and
then
um transferred the manual control uh
from the space station so I went back to
their spacecraft uh soy's 11 and you
know
commenced like going back to Earth
so for a while like it flew in co-orbit
with the space station
and then kind of like retrofired off in
its own Direction like to go back to
earth like and do their re-entry
now before they re-entered the Earth's
atmosphere uh they had the work
compartment and the service module and
they were jettisoned like was supposed
to happen it was completely fine and
normal like everything was uneventful
um but then shortly after that radio
communication abruptly ended uh which
probably earlier than it should have
now about half an hour later more like
25 minutes later
soyuz 11's automatic systems because
everything was automated at this point
um landed the spacecraft right like it
landed like it was supposed to
everything seemed like it was completely
and utterly normal uh you know the
spacecraft coming back to Earth now uh
at this point when it landed
the uh the crew had been on this
spacecraft and you know the whole
mission was 570 hours and they had done
383 orbits around the Earth
so you know the spacecraft lands
everybody goes there to like retrieve it
everybody thinks everything is fine
there is no indication that there is
anything wrong however when they open
the capsule of the soyuz 11 all three of
the crew are dead
so they uh yeah they flew back to Earth
everything was normal but they were all
dead inside
um so basically they say this is a quote
from the chair of the state commission
whose name was Karim karimov he says
outwardly there was no damage whatsoever
they knocked on the side but there was
no response from within on opening the
hatch they found all three men in their
couches motionless with dark blue
patches on their faces and trails of
blood from their noses and ears carbon
dioxide they removed them from The
Descent module dubrovsky was still warm
the doctors gave artificial respiration
and they actually have there is um
floating around because I've seen it
there is actually a footage of this of
them giving them like CPR uh out in the
field and stuff uh obviously they were
uh dead by this point
um but yeah uh based on their reports
the cause of death was Suffocation
Suffocation what ended up happening was
that uh apparently was that there was a
breathing ventilation valve which was
between the orbital module and The
Descent module and that had been uh kind
of like jolted open as The Descent
module separated from the service module
which was about 12 minutes after they
retro fired and um what okay so
apparently these two modules were held
together by you know they have those
explosive bolts yeah what they were
supposed to do like a sequence like bolt
bolt bolt uh what happened they think
was that all the bolts actually fired
simultaneously and instead of in
sequence like they were supposed to and
that the force of them all firing at
once caused the internal mechanism of
the pressure Equalization valve to
loosen a seal
um and you know it's just like
drastically lowered the cabin pressure
and probably killed all of them within a
few seconds the valve was actually
located underneath the seats and you
couldn't like
you couldn't get to it and block it in
time like so it was massive cabin
depression yeah is that what it was yep
okay so it actually
not true Suffocation per se they
suffocated because of depressurized
so they were unconscious immediately
yeah they said within 40 seconds
probably yeah they're probably wondering
what the [ __ ] happened
um because they did have like their um
one at least one they got some uh data
from one of the cosmonauts that had um
his outfit had biomedical sensors on it
and they said that Cardiac Arrest
occurred within 40 seconds of the
pressure loss so yeah they probably died
like they didn't look like they were
because that was the creepy thing that
was the creepiest thing about this to me
is that they didn't know that the
astronauts were dead in there like the
the capsule came back to Earth automated
and it was everything was normal like
they didn't think anything was wrong
technical error but then like when they
opened it all of them were dead and they
were just like laying in there like
because they were like normal that's
because it the depressurization was so
violent it probably knocked him out
instantly yeah which like I said
instantly unconscious and then they
suffocated yeah
now they did say that one of them uh
potsiev that his body was actually found
a little bit near the valve so he might
have tried like seeing what was going on
like for example but he didn't have
enough time to like do anything about it
they said even if he had known what was
going on like he wouldn't have had time
depressurization's violent
yeah
they look but the weird thing is that I
saw like I said I saw the footage
because it got um Declassified like
later on and you can find it like it's
on like a bunch of videos It's on
YouTube nowadays but the bodies look
pretty normal I mean they're just like
out in the field they don't look all
[ __ ] up or anything yeah but it's kind
of like getting slapped in a [ __ ]
head you know what I mean yeah like
imagine uh you know like if you're ever
in an airplane or you're going up in a
mountain or something you don't mean to
pressure in your ears you gotta blow it
imagine that happening a lot worse a lot
faster right that that could knock
render a man unconscious in pretty much
immediately maybe other guys might
resist it depending on how you know
good luck maybe you know but and uh
chances are they were [ __ ]
immediately were knocked unconscious
that's what they that's what they think
happened they said like easily like
within 30 40 seconds well he died within
30 40 seconds yeah because that's when
Carter had arrested but I think they
were unconscious immediately like I said
you kind of hoped that they were yeah to
be honest with you now
um
the thing about this one is I guess like
the Soviet media tried to like I guess
they couldn't cover it up completely
because it was like kind of a big deal
um but they did try to kind of like
downplay it being like well yeah they
died but you know the mission was
successful technically even though they
were all dead when they got back
um you know because I mean it did come
back like the the thing came back like
it was supposed to it's just that they
were all dead inside because of an
accident you know what I mean
um so but the thing about it though was
that they tried to keep the actual cause
of death like under wraps for a couple
of years afterwards
um which I kind of feel like the us at
that time was working on Skylab and
because they were kind of like watching
what the Soviets were doing they were
kind of like a little bit worried about
it because they were kind of doing like
some similar [ __ ] and they're just like
well why won't they tell like what
exactly did they die of because we want
to be able to like you know plan for
that contingency like in our thing
um so there was kind of that kind of
[ __ ] too but what's funny is that we
were always bagging on Soviet technology
but only people that don't really
understand it bag on it Soviet military
technology was super good
I just said it's simple it's simple it's
easy to mass produce because it's all
disposable anyway
they're not fighting for [ __ ]
contracts like the like our country is
where they're fighting for big contracts
with good commissions and [ __ ] it's not
it's not quite the same
well that Soviet
era space technology
some of that [ __ ] came directly out of
the [ __ ] 60s and 70s they were still
using it well just a few years ago
before SpaceX was resupply and Scott uh
that damn
International Space Station the the
Russians were doing it with Soviet era
technology kinda
it's because they it was proven it was
cheap and real reliable simple wasn't
much to go wrong with it and they're
learning it in this phase you know
there's a lot to be said for a simple
basic
[ __ ] that works you know they just kind
of keep everything real simple I mean
the more you complicate stuff the more
[ __ ] that can go wrong
Americans are kind of because of
especially younger ones kind of
brainwashed through video games to be
kind of technophiliacs
to where oh man that's not high
technology the highest technology is
this new [ __ ]
in a combat environment I've been it
I've been in it you know what I'm in
[ __ ] the worst 40 50 degrees below
zero up in Korea you don't want high
technology high technology is the is
simple
minimal something that just is can be
very dependent on it you can depend on
it in [ __ ] extreme conditions
if it's real complicated you can't hand
it out to the average [ __ ] Joe
and then put him in a 40 degree below
zero and then that same piece of
equipment in a desert and that same
piece of equipment out in a rain forest
anything complicated is destroyed you
know just it just doesn't make it
and some of our weapons are like that
Soviets are still using them same damn
tanks the only thing they changed was
how much the armor was the thickness of
the armor and what kind of motor
other than that it's the same thing that
they had from the 50s maybe they had
some Electronics to it
it's just a tank though those get
destroyed anyway
so just make a lot of them it's it
it's a better way of doing it well like
I said I kind of feel like it depends on
the situation that you're talking about
like sometimes high-tech [ __ ] is better
but yeah a lot of times depending on the
application yeah
um sometimes simple stuff will work out
it works better be in a military you
never know what the situation is going
to be
so the best thing is the default is is
dumb caveman [ __ ] that always works
that's the way to go well and I'm kind
of like the kind because I'm kind of
like a person that doesn't really like I
don't like a lot of bells and whistles
that I'm not gonna use yeah yeah yeah so
I kind of feel like if I'm gonna buy an
appliance for example
like a refrigerator
um you know I want an ice maker out of
it but I don't need all the stuff that
it's like oh it knows when you're out of
certain things I'm like look I can open
it and see when I'm out of certain
things it's like I don't really need
that kind of crap because to me it just
seems like the more [ __ ] you add on
there yeah it's neat but that's just
more [ __ ] that's gonna break yeah that
I'm gonna have to pay to have to fix so
no thanks for you
um military files you know
I can work with the AK platform or the
AR platform I love them both all right
they have their own strengths and
weaknesses
the AK strength is is the more of them
you make the cheaper they are when
you're when a factory is fully fired up
they're twenty dollars a piece for an AK
rifle and you can hand it out to anybody
and anybody can make it and you can hand
it out to anybody and they can shoot off
some rounds
is it as good as an AR
and ARS has a lot more accessories a
little more refined better controls
there's a lot
I'd say technically no
but when it comes to equipping a large
amount of people quickly cheaply with
something that works every time that is
effective no the AKA
but it's situation
but if you say it Ross we're going to
send you to an alien planet you don't
know what it's going to be like when you
get there you want to take the AR the
AKs to give me the AK because I know
that AEK will [ __ ] work on Mars
because it's just so stupid dumb you
know it's simple
but the thing about it it was that uh
you know as horrifying as this accident
was uh again much like the Apollo
mission where the guys burned up they
did uh kind of like look at
what happened in this case and like how
they can improve things so after this
happened they actually designed
redesigned like the soyuz spacecraft one
of the things they did was instead of
cramming three dudes into the spacecraft
they actually made it so that only two
cosmonauts would go so that the two
cosmonauts could wear uh the spacesuits
during the launch on the landing which
like I said seems like a no-brainer
nowadays but I guess they didn't really
do it back then you know so that was
like a lot safer
um and honestly like the space suits
that they wore back then like they're
still using like modified versions that
nowadays so yeah so it did kind of like
uh you know
were something that we said for simple
[ __ ] man
it is
they're still using that same suit okay
well A variation it's not exactly an
evolution of it yeah yeah and the thing
about it was that they had to like
redesign the thing because like I said
they were trying to cram three dudes in
there and there wasn't room for them to
wear spacesuits yeah um but they're like
hey if we redesign it so that only two
guys go then they can wear the suits and
it's much safer and so that's kind of
like what they what they got out of that
so let's talk about the Challenger in
the Columbia disaster okay here we go
and then we'll get into the Lost
Cosmonaut uh kind of story oh I know
which one you're talking about because I
kind of feel like that's kind of that's
the creepiest of the creepiest one yeah
although I'm not sure how much of it is
true but yeah yeah because I kind of
feel like it's urban legend but you know
what I mean nobody knows it's so um well
people know it's just that
but yeah oh that's right more [ __ ] came
out about that right yeah right yeah so
the Challenger disaster and like I said
this is one that I remember because I
was in junior high when this happened
and this was my brother's 10th birthday
and I distinctly remember him getting
like really really upset about it
um and me seeing it on TV like when it
happened because I was at school
so in case you were not alive this
actually happened in 1986 January 28
1986. uh the Challenger was blasting off
from Cape Canaveral Florida
um only about 50 miles south from where
I was born and grew up
uh and Seven astronauts on board were
killed
now the primary Mission uh of this
shuttle launch was they were gonna do uh
they were actually launching the second
of the tracking a data relay satellites
and they also had um what they call the
Spartan Haley spacecraft and it was like
a little satellite and they were gonna
like launch it from Challenger and they
were gonna pick it up two days later
because it was Haley's Comet it was 1986
and um Haley's comment was going to be
like as closest approach to the Sun so
they wanted to like study what was going
on with that so they had two things like
going on
now as somebody mentioned a long time
ago like at the beginning of the show
um probably the most famous
aspect of this mission
was that Krista McAuliffe uh from
Concord New Hampshire who was a teacher
uh she was actually the winner of a
national screening uh of somebody that
was going to go up into space so they
you know they they did like a lot of
advertising and I remember like seeing
her picture like all over the news and
[ __ ] like that and she was very excited
about going up in space and she was
gonna do a couple like lessons from
outer space like with her kids and
everything like her kids were like super
excited her students and stuff and she
was going to
um you know lecture students over the
nine-month mission or whatever and they
were gonna try because they were trying
to like
show like how important teachers were
like getting into people into like
science and technology fields and [ __ ]
like that
so uh so there was her and then there
was like the other members of the crew
who's the commander who was uh dick
scoby he had the pilot who was Michael
Smith Mission specialist uh Ellison
onizuka uh Judith Resnick and Ronald
McNair and Hughes aircraft engineer
Gregory Jarvis that was the entire crew
now the mission actually
um and I kind of remember this happening
I mean I was how old was I I was 14 when
this happened
so they had been having problems like
even before the [ __ ] launched uh the
launch was actually
postponed for several days like was
supposed to go up earlier
um but they had some problems with uh
the previous shuttle mission which was
Colombia
um which they were trying to like land
and it was like that was getting delayed
so they were
so they were already kind of behind
because of that
now and I remember this happening too on
the night before the Challenger launch
uh right here in Central Florida where
it launches from we had a really really
bad cold snap which we don't usually
have but it happens every now and then
so we had like a really really bad cold
wave and it put a bunch of ice onto the
launch pad
so on the day that it was supposed to
launch and like I said it had already
been delayed a few days uh but it was
January 28th liftoff was actually
supposed to happen much earlier in the
morning but it was too cold so they
actually delayed it until 11 38 a.m was
when it was supposed to go so like
almost noon because they thought it
would be warm enough then
now everything seemed okay at first
um but after the vehicle emerged from
what they call Max Q which is the period
of greatest aerodynamic pressure yeah
um the mission control told the uh
Mission Commander okay Challenger go
with throttle up
so it launched
but 73 seconds after liftoff
uh it exploded at an altitude of 46 000
feet now I remember
this is [ __ ] up because I remember
like nobody knew because it was a bunch
of people like at the you know obviously
like a bunch of people go to Cape
Canaveral like to see it every time like
the shuttle goes off and
even when I watched on TV later like you
didn't realize exactly what you were
looking at you know what I mean like it
kind of goes up and then like and you
were like wait was that that wasn't
supposed to happen but like that does it
look right you know what I mean
um but yes it was like really really
alarming
so they did actually like manage to
salvage some tapes from the wreckage and
like I said about a second or two before
um Challenger broke up uh exploded
um basically like the commander like he
said uh oh and that was about it like
nothing else was recorded after that
which is I don't know that creeps me out
for some reason
um and for more than an hour after that
like they just had debris like raining
down from the sky like into the Atlantic
Ocean I remember yeah I remember this
too I was too actually I was down on
break from school
because I just lived I just lived like
basically across the street from a high
school in Michigan when that happened
I think I was on break when I saw it
yeah we turned a TV on into my house and
went well [ __ ]
because I think it was lunch I think it
was lunch break yeah because I was at I
think I was in seventh grade I want to
say I was in seventh grade or eighth
grade I can't remember I was like in
11th or 10th and I was we were in the
cafeteria because it was I mean it was
early
it was like a little bit before noon but
we had lunch early because you know they
did it in shifts
and we I remember coming back from lunch
and like there were people in the hall
that were waiting to go to lunch they
were the next one to go and they said oh
my God you guys like the shuttle
exploded and I was like shut up it did
not I thought they were [ __ ] around
and then like we went into my English it
was my English class and we went into my
English classroom and our teacher I
think it was Mrs Hutchinson actually she
comes in and she's like yeah the shuttle
exploded and she rolled in the TV and
then we watched it on the news so we
didn't see it happen live but we saw it
happen like as soon as we got back from
lunch because we thought they were
[ __ ] around we thought they were like
shut up that's not gold that's not funny
you know what I mean remember seeing
that explosion within the two booster
rocket Trails coming up out of it man
that's [ __ ] up man and then they kept
showing the photograph of that teacher
yeah espresso McAuliffe yeah
well because she wasn't I mean she was
an astronaut they trained her obviously
but she got picked like in a nationwide
and they were just like excited it's
like wait we're sending a civilian like
up there and she's a teacher and this
was the first one I think it was yeah
she got blown up can you imagine like
all her students were like watching it I
think that maybe like so sad and it's
like it's sad that they all died
obviously but I think that
that they like went so hard on that like
and all her and I remember like all her
kids like made like little stuff out of
construction paper like all that kind of
stuff and I'm like oh man can you
imagine like yeah that's like your
teacher and you loved her and everything
and you're watching it and just like
well you're gonna get another reason how
why it happened right yeah okay good but
us like yeah I can't imagine like that
when she gets into the worst when she
gets into the reasons why it happens I'm
gonna [ __ ] go off but go ahead
people are going to like it you think
yeah yeah me going off on it
because he I was never a [ __ ]
space shuttle fan when I was a kid saw
it I [ __ ] loved it but then when I
got older and understood what it was
that they missed out on
no space shuttle was a bad idea
go ahead go ahead
okay
yeah so they start looking for the crew
and they didn't find them um spoiler
alert they did find them later but I
don't think any of them were still in
one piece if that's uh not too [ __ ] up
to say
so uh after this happened obviously the
shuttle program was immediately grounded
so NASA immediately like as they would
did an investigation so they had a
commission put together
uh you had like it was actually the
commission was chaired by the former
secretary of state state Rogers and then
they had like other members of the
commission were like uh Neil Armstrong
was on the commission Sally Ride Like
You Know astronauts you also had uh
Chuck Yeager the test pilot and uh
physicist Richard Feynman who you know
he was on there as well and he was kind
of the one that demonstrated like what
had gone wrong
so basically it was just kind of like
and I think we alluded to this like a
little bit earlier
was that because they I kind of feel
like they wanted too much out of this
program and they didn't have the money
or the manpower to really realize it so
they were kind of seemed like they were
cutting Corners they were trying to like
push stuff further than it probably
should have been pushed
um and NASA had been
suffering under this for a while like
they were kind of like underfunded they
didn't really have enough money to do
what they were like expected to be doing
um and it really didn't like uh work out
so basically what happened
that they found out later on
uh the cause of the accident was uh the
severe cold like I said it doesn't
usually get cold in Florida but for
whatever reason it was very particularly
like uh cold on this particular day and
what happened was that the cold reduced
the resiliency of the two rubber O-rings
that sealed The Joint between the two
lower segments of the right hand solid
rocket booster uh Richard Feynman
actually like at the commission where he
was trying to demonstrate what went
wrong he took one of the O-rings and
like submerged it in ice water to like
show what uh what happened with it so
basically like um if circumstances were
the way they should be
um you know the shuttle has three main
engines and when they ignited they would
you know push the vehicle forward as
that they were supposed to do and the
boosters get ignited when the vehicle
swings back to Center but what ended up
on this particular happened this
particular morning was really cold uh
there was an effect called Joint
rotation and this prevented the Rings
from resealing and opened a path for a
bunch of hot exhaust gas to escape from
inside the booster and they didn't
really see it because it was on a side
that was not uh you know visible to the
cameras exactly
like made this big
leak and it just like expanded as it was
going and then after about a minute
there was this big eight foot stream of
flame that came out from the hole and
then it was a 40-foot stream of flame
and it eroded one of the struts that
secured one of the boosters base to the
large external tank carrying the liquid
hydrogen and the liquid oxygen for the
Orbiter engines and pretty much blew the
whole [ __ ] up
now
um the thing about it though is that
honestly the only way to have prevented
this accident was not to have launched
it yeah I can even bring it on the way
to avoid this accident is not to have a
space shuttle well yeah but I mean
that's that that barn door has already
yeah yeah that yeah I'm gonna get to
that in a minute
so yes I mean they basically they didn't
know that it was going to happen but
they said basically once it launched
there was nothing really they could have
done um they said even if they had seen
the [ __ ] happening like at liftoff
um there wouldn't have been enough time
to save the crew uh so yeah now the
[ __ ] up thing about it and we kind of
like alluded to this earlier as I
mentioned is that even though the
Challenger and you can see it on the
like you know it's really upsetting to
watch but
it did break break up in the explosion
but the forward section that had the
crew in it like the crew cabin
um was like broke off in one piece and
it actually continued going upward with
the rest of the debris because of the
four four of momentum
um and then went down and like plummeted
into the ocean so as I said they don't
know for sure obviously because they
weren't in there they did think that the
crew survived the initial breakup of the
shuttle but that probably uh cabin
pressure loss was immediate it they
probably went unconscious within a few
seconds so they probably were not alive
like when they were plummeting down or
were not conscious at least I mean I
hope they weren't because that would be
all right that cabin would have been
spinning like crazy under high G
yeah they'd have been [ __ ] sucked
down and knocked unconscious through all
that [ __ ] I mean they wouldn't know what
the [ __ ] was going on I just remember
like I remember after that happened and
there were like all these like rumors
were only like oh my God like they knew
what was happening like all the way down
to the [ __ ] yeah they're calling oh
[ __ ] on the way down right which like I
said I get it like I understand like
people come up with those stories and
stuff like that but they I mean they
don't think unless they're just telling
us that to make us feel better yeah but
um but probably decompression yeah I I
don't think that they would have been
conscious for most of that okay I'm
gonna go off now this is a good time to
go out yeah well yeah I'm gonna run to
the bathroom okay see she wanna hear me
going off no I just have to go to the
bathroom
here's the problem
here's the problem with space shuttle
the space shuttle is typical
Western Germanic
[ __ ] thinking all right the Germans
are even worse than us Americans at this
what they'll do is they say well we have
a complicated problem go into space and
coming back this is a complicated
problem so we're going to make a
complicated machine to fulfill this to
get this complicated problem done
when you look at a space shuttle you got
the main fuel tank you got the shuttle
riding on the back with [ __ ] rockets
on the end of the shuttle you got the
two solid booster Rockets there's a lot
of joints and there's a lot of [ __ ]
weird shape and you can just look at
that thing and go man that is not
supposed to be in the [ __ ] air that
is not simplicity it just isn't
technology is not about making more and
making [ __ ] more complicated when you do
that especially in an extreme
environment
you're asking for [ __ ] trouble
what you need is you need D engineering
the technology is in making something
simple
you have a [ __ ] complicated problem
that is solved by a simple machine but
to get that done you need complicated
mathematical technology to get the
[ __ ] engineering done
but when they when the engineering and
all the paperwork is done and the
Machine is made it is simple but it
defeats a complicated task
the Russians were great at that
the Russians were great at D engineering
they can make something simple
that could do a complicated task that's
where technology really is
because it becomes more reliable cheaper
uh safer
if the United the United States had a
huge [ __ ] budget
had we taken that huge budget a huge
budget compared to the Russians
had we had an American budget
but with the Soviet design philosophy of
de-engineering and simplicity we would
have had a much better [ __ ] Space
Program
it would have been more streamlined it
probably would have been something more
like around the Saturn heavy lifters it
would have looked more like a rocket it
had been more dependable and cheaper and
had been more effective you'd have
gotten more tonnage up in space per year
that's what made Orion like I talked
about it earlier so beautiful
the technology was in the mathematics
the technology was all in the damn
mathematics behind the damn fuel pellet
that little mini atomic bomb the rest of
it was all 1920s technology you could
have did that [ __ ] in the 20s it was
just a [ __ ] Coke bottle machine
that's proven technology
it was basically a coke bottle machine
inside of a [ __ ] metal [ __ ]
nuclear submarine with a [ __ ]
concrete nose cone on it hahaha
dumb technology but that would have
worked that would have worked for
you want the technology is not in making
something more complicated the
technology is in de-engineering
something down into being it's simple
that's where technology is
have we taken that philosophy we'd have
been decades ahead by now
okay I'm gonna get off my soapbox you
wanna uh another drink yeah I'm like I'm
I'm getting into that ginger ale and
yeah it's good spice rum it's not bad I
wasn't sure I liked it when I first
drank it but I'm just like no because
it's it takes a while to like kind of
grow on you
Jeffy Hart said I remember being in
first grade and hearing it on the PA in
class and then got home and walked in to
see my little sister crying in the
living room it was a rough day yeah like
I said I don't know if you were here
earlier but
um January 28th I remember it very
vividly January 28 19 uh 1986 was my
little brother's 10th birthday and
because the shuttle exploded on his
birthday uh he was kind of [ __ ] up for
like a while after that because I kind
of feel like he thought because he was
just 10 he thought that it was like
something to do with him or you know
what I mean so
so it's weird that I still like kind of
remember that but I actually remember
86 I think I was in seventh it was
seventh grade or eighth eighth grade and
I remember not seeing it live because I
because we were at lunch we were in the
cafeteria because it was early we had
early lunch I remember that I'm pretty
sure it was seventh grade seventh grade
objh
Ormond Beach Junior High which is now
Ormond Beach Middle Middle School but
back then they called it Junior High
I just remember coming back and
everybody telling me the shuttle
exploded and we thinking that they we
were all thinking they were like trying
to be funny you know what I mean but
then like they brought in the TV and
then we went outside like to look at it
and I was just kind of like in a way I'm
kind of glad because had we not been at
lunch I mean every time the shuttle went
off because like I said we're in Florida
so you go outside and you can see the
shuttle code it's like right there you
know what I mean it was only like a few
miles away
so you know where I grew up in Daytona
it was 40 50 miles south so you could
once it was up you could see it like
pretty clearly
so we would always go outside like if
you were at school they would let you go
outside and like watch it everybody go
out on the lawn and be like ooh you know
what I mean so all so all those kids
were out there watching it and it blew
up and they like didn't know what was
going on they were like looking at each
going what the [ __ ] like what happened
that doesn't look right because we'd
seen it before like I said I didn't it
just so I'd seen other live launches
from school but I didn't happen to see
that because it just happened to take
place like when I was at lunch so I
didn't see it live but we saw it on the
TV like afterward but yeah everybody it
was a weird oh man it was a weird day
and I remember like my English teacher
she like started crying like when she
saw it on TV and like everybody was like
because the kids they didn't know what
the [ __ ] was going on they were just
kind of like freaking out you know what
I mean they're like oh my God are they
still in their ew it's like oh yeah it
was [ __ ] up
so basically so what happened after that
like I said
um that kind of um I feel like the
challenge or disaster it sort of like
brought into Stark relief uh you know
some endemic problems that are going on
with NASA like I said under funding
there was all kind of other stuff and
and probably like Tom was saying it just
seemed like
they were spending all this money on it
but I kind of feel like you know from a
military standpoint from that kind of
stuff they didn't think it was like
reliable enough to get all the [ __ ] up
there like where where they needed it to
be
so NASA was just like look we we don't
think we can get this program again like
do you guys want us to like build
another one like to replace this or
what's the deal and they didn't really
get any word on it
um and NASA said look we're not going to
be ready to like fly another shuttle
mission until like 1988 which is like
two years later
um and you know the White House Reagan
was in and Congress were like you know
we don't really know like should we
build another one or anything like that
um what oh
it's just my candy
isn't that good
but you know the the ones that were kind
of like advocating for the shuttle
program were like well we need at least
another one to replace that we might
need two more because 90s are coming up
and we have all these like defense and
scientific stuff like we need to do that
we need a live launch in space like for
satellites and stuff so we need to do
all this stuff so um and also they were
gonna start building the you know
International Space Station so there was
that too so basically after that like
Reagan comes out and says okay well you
need to build a replacement shuttle
Orbiter which uh later would be named
Endeavor
um and said you need to get started on
that like to tweet
so
um but they kind of like made it so that
you couldn't just like pay to have your
[ __ ] like on the shuttle it was just
gonna be like for Science and defense
and that was it you know what I mean
that's kind of like what they did
so I kind of feel like the shuttle
program like works okay for like a
little while but then came 2003 and then
there was another
disaster the Columbia disaster now like
I said Colombia
that was one of the oldest ones right
because I'm pretty sure that I saw
Colombia launching in 81. yeah the first
one was Enterprise
I remember that I thought Enterprise was
the later one no Enterprise was the
first one named after the Star Trek
Starship Enterprise yeah maybe but I
definitely it was later I definitely
remember seeing Columbia launching in 81
because I remember we drove down yeah it
was around by then I think we drove down
to Cocoa Beach like to Cape Canaveral
like to see the Columbia go off but yeah
so the Columbia like Colombia had been
like up and down like many many times uh
but yeah it also uh broke up in 2003 uh
killing all Seven astronauts on board
and this was before this was actually
not after launch this was when it was
trying to land at Kennedy's entry yeah
yeah
so yeah so like I said Colombia yeah it
says made the the shuttle program's
first flight into space in 1981. so
Colombia okay not Enterprise I thought
Enterprise no like I said Enterprise I
thought was later because I was pretty
sure
see I was like questioning myself but I
was pretty sure I was nine and we drove
down
we drove down to Cape Canaveral and saw
Columbia go off and it was a big deal
because that was the first one and it
was 1981. okay yeah I thought I remember
that correctly I remembered Enterprise
no mentioned in [ __ ] the early Star
Trek films
all right I was sure I was remembering
that right like I said it might have
been a second I saw it
did they even have one called Enterprise
yeah
I know they had Endeavor yeah Columbia
Challenger
I can't remember what the other ones
were calling but I saw the Columbus I
saw Columbia go up in 81 and like I said
I'm pretty sure that was the first one
because I remember it being like a super
big deal
so uh so yeah so the Columbia so
Colombia goes off
uh in January of 2003 for its 28th
mission
and there was a bunch of other of stuff
that it was supposed to be doing like
there was a bunch of experiments on
there like a bunch of stuff that had
like microgravity
so the crew as I said it was seven
people you had your uh Commander whose
name was Rick Husband the Pilot's name
was William McCool you had your mission
specialist uh Michael Anderson David
Brown kalpana Chala and Laurel Clark and
a payload specialist Elan Ramon who was
actually the first Israeli astronaut
now as Colombia was re-entering the
Earth's atmosphere uh it actually broke
apart Over Texas at 9 00 a.m Eastern
Standard Time at an altitude of 40 miles
and showered debris across Southeastern
Texas and Southern Louisiana
uh so yeah so they got it on radar it's
on camera and everything like that I
kind of remember this happening but I've
never seen it I don't think I was
watching it live though again I just saw
a video I I remember maybe I didn't
actually see it I remembered seeing
video
of it come in look like a shooting star
it's [ __ ] up yeah it's [ __ ] up
so I'm pretty sure I don't think it was
a reenactment that was like back on back
I just remember being weirded out
because like I think that I didn't see
it because I didn't see it live but then
I remembered hearing about it I was like
Columbia holy [ __ ] I saw that go up the
first time yeah when I was a little kid
in 1981 and then like it blew up I just
remember I remember being being on CNN
and they were showing it over and over
again it looked like a damn shooting
star but CNN would show fake [ __ ] they
might have been showing a video of a
[ __ ] shooting star I don't know
well like I said I don't remember I
don't remember this one as vividly as as
Challenger because I saw that one happen
like right after so I don't remember
what this one looked like uh or not but
the thing that happened about this one
so even though it broke up on re-entry
like when it was Landing they said what
actually happened uh that caused this to
happen
was this was actually launch related as
well
when they viewed films of the launch of
the column of Colombia
it looks like there was a piece of like
foam that was like insulating foam
and it when it was launching it broke
off from the external propellant tank
and struck the Leading Edge of the left
wing uh about 81 seconds after takeoff
so the thing about it was that like
little bits of foam like this had kind
of come off in past missions before and
like nothing bad had happened so I guess
they didn't really think it was that big
of a deal
um because they didn't think the foam
was like heavy enough or have enough
momentum to like cause any damage this
is all theoretical people well like well
like I said it had happened before like
and nothing bad had happened yeah so
this was like the first time that this
had you know been this I kind of think
they never did know what it was that's
what I I remember thinking that at the
time that they well I think that might
have been an excuse but we'll go we'll
see we'll see
all right they saw that happen they kept
showing that video over and over again
that piece of foam falling
but I had a feeling that they weren't
convinced that that's really what it was
well they did tests after like they
tried to replicate it and in the
replication tests they found that in
fact even though previously they had
thought that the foam was not traveling
fast enough or heavy enough to cause any
damage but in some of the tests they did
see that some of the foam was actually
capable of punching a big hole in the
reinforced uh insulation tiles that are
on the outside of the nose and the wing
um and they were like oh well [ __ ]
um we didn't think anything would go
wrong but in some of the tests uh it did
kind of replicate the conditions that
had happened there so there so there was
a chance back to the drawing board now
um so yeah so I guess some Engineers had
wanted
um
even previously to launch their like
they thought maybe the foam was capable
of doing some [ __ ] like that and they so
they wanted like some films taken and
stuff like that but apparently like you
know paperwork was lost and it didn't
really work out at the way they wanted
to see how I always thought
that that foam fell regularly and lots
of these [ __ ] shuttles [ __ ]
launched
well they said that they said it had
fallen before they'd seen it but it
hadn't done any damage so they thought
that it wasn't capable of doing damn
because it wasn't going it must have
been very unlikely because lots of them
launched and came back well that's yeah
that's what I mean that's why they
thought that it wasn't anything to be
alarmed about because they said oh well
we've seen that happen before and it
didn't do anything bad but it just
happened that under these wrong
conditions uh it just happened that it
fell exactly the right way and I was
under the impression I was under the
impression that it was this occurrence
that this it was this case
that [ __ ] convinced NASA that they
had to move away from the space shuttle
there's too many problems with it
and that they didn't right away
eventually they did but I think this is
why well after this accident they
actually grounded uh the three shuttles
that were left which were the discovery
the Atlantis and the Endeavor
um and basically they went back to the
drawing board like I said and they like
they went to NASA and was like basically
we have to figure out like how to keep
this from happening again
um and one of the things that came in uh
as a result of this was that they put
kits on the ship like where you could
fix the [ __ ] like if it happened like
inflate it was all for [ __ ] nothing
though when you think about it people
because
SpaceX is doing the same job that that
the space shuttle did for a fraction of
the cost a fret and there's no people
involved there's no crew totally robotic
reusable Rockets
theoretically
that technology was available probably
in 2003 they could have done that it's
just
the space [ __ ] program was [ __ ]
they weren't really on the ball in 2003
to that in the 2000s they
Private Industry [ __ ] kicked their
asses well the shuttle actually went
back into service in 2005. yeah which uh
in summer right so yeah
uh And Justice For Me said like you said
I'm amazed we didn't lose more
astronauts me too like the more I read
about this like the more I researched
this I'm like holy crap like only
I'm just only 19 astronauts have died
like that they know of but I was like
that seems remarkably low considering
how [ __ ] dangerous the [ __ ] is and
considering how many accidents they've
had you know what I mean yeah like while
they were figuring this [ __ ] out so in a
way that's kind of amazing like 19
that's too many obviously but
I wouldn't I would have thought that it
would have been they got way more than
that because they did they did the Space
Shuttle shuttle design was [ __ ] too
complicated and unsound
it just that's not how you do it
it should have used [ __ ] Saturn
Saturn heavy lift
and re-engineered a different nose cones
more modern nose cones but you should
have used those boosters then it had
been so much better
but for some reason they wanted a fake
space plane
just you know whatever then he said
trillions of things can go wrong at any
time yeah that's that's what's weird
about it's just like like I said The
more complicated the [ __ ] is like the
more [ __ ] can break you know what I mean
so the fact that they only only lost 19.
no I'm not just talking about American
I'm talking about cosmonauts and
everything the fact that they only lost
19 that's a testament to like how people
had their [ __ ] together yeah you know
but the Saturn boosters were [ __ ]
proven and and simple and dumb you know
I mean they they worked there was like
something to Russia would make because
it was it it was about to Ching
chi-ching that that's
what it was
I would have built it
I would have built it all around Saturn
boosters because you did the work why
waste them
you know
Jeff yard said I believe the Enterprise
was constructed as one of the first
orbiters for test flights maybe that's
what it was but I'm not sure if it was
used for actually yeah he's right no I
think they postpone Enterprise yeah
because I was like that wasn't a Shuttle
Enterprise was the one that was on the
[ __ ] top of that 747 they were flying
around that's the one I remember that
one from a kid said that you're right
you called it because like I said I was
pretty sure I saw the first space
shuttle line no yeah Enterprise which
was the one that was on top of 747 and
they don't unhook it and it would land
on its own to test yeah yeah I remember
that's the one I was thinking about yeah
so I didn't think it was kind of like it
never launched I guess right it wasn't
it wasn't a tempting test vehicle so all
right so let's get into the last thing
which is the Lost cosmonauts which I
think is what you wanted to talk about
yeah yeah it's a creepy one so although
like I said I don't know how I think a
lot of it's [ __ ] but we'll get into
that so uh so yeah lost cosmonauts or
sometimes they call it the Phantom
cosmonauts so there this is kind of like
a bunch of interrelated theories I kind
of feel like
um where it's like a bunch of
conspiracies which allege that uh some
Soviet cosmonauts went to outer space
but they either like were lost and like
drifted off into space or they died and
like it did you re-entry like they you
know the [ __ ] was all like covered up
now
I kind of feel like the conspiracy
theories surrounding this have been
bolstered by some actual [ __ ] that like
I talked about before where they did
kind of try to cover stuff up but it did
come out like later on that these people
had died and [ __ ] like that
um so yeah so there's some reason to
think that maybe they were like keeping
some secrets and everything but I'm not
really sure like how
much evidence there is for a lot of this
stuff but we'll get into that
so
um prior to Yuri gagarin's first space
flight apparently
allegedly the Soviet Union had maybe
armed some humans into space and the
[ __ ] didn't go so well
um so there have been conspiracy
theories about that ever since and the
information has supposedly been
suppressed uh now I will say that the
evidence
um supporting any of these kind of
interrelated conspiracy theories is uh
inconclusive at best and some of the
stuff they later found out was actually
like actual hoaxes like they actually
proved they were hoaxes so you know it
would take just take it all with the
grain of salt is what I'm saying
so obviously um you know the whole Space
Race period between you know mid 1950s
so like the early 1970s uh you know you
had a big thing about like Soviet Union
us they're trying to like get into space
and they're trying to like outdo one
another and feeling like that so there
was a lot of incentive I guess to make
some [ __ ] up
so the Soviets were actually the first
ones into space launching uh Sputnik
into orbit and uh and in 1961 Cosmonaut
Yuri Gagarin was actually the first man
in space so the US started like kind of
freaking out like we're gonna lose to
the Soviets
um but the Soviets had some weird [ __ ]
going on that
now some of this stuff like I said is
not conspiracy like some of this stuff
actually they did find out later on did
happen like for example in 1960 there
was a Soviet rocket that actually
ignited on the launching pad
and killed between 78 and 120 people
when I was remembering uh on the that
was like the ground crew yeah ground
crew now for a long time they kept that
a secret but it came out later on
look let me say something for you on the
back of that one the Soviet guy in
charge the rocket program was so pissed
over that accident
and
that every launch after that he would
[ __ ] sit out there in a goddamn chair
on the [ __ ] launch pad with other
[ __ ] top
ground crew people and watch the launch
at close range so if that [ __ ] blew up
they would all die together
that was his thing to make quality
assurance
we're all going to sit out there on the
damn launch pad when this next one
launches
good thinking in a way but that's just
the Soviet way of thinking about it
putting your putting you you put the
leaders lives on the line
I mean you know probably a good idea
yeah that way they couldn't slack they
couldn't slack off because they could be
sitting right there on a damn chair
watching the launch at like a [ __ ] a
couple hundred meters like
because when that [ __ ] blew it blew up
like an atomic bomb
the one she's talking about they they
evidently had films of it I think I
actually seen the films I've seen films
of huge explosions and I think it's the
one that they're I mean like I said the
film is just filtered out because there
is a film of that soyuz 11 like I did
see that film so that has been
Declassified of them trying to like
level the whole [ __ ] launch facility
it was a big explosion huge explosion
I've seen I'm not sure like um I've seen
some sources say 78 people died um some
sources at 120 people died but it was a
lot of people like it was just like all
the ground crew and they kept it a
secret for a long time but it's been
declass just like General Bucky says man
they got Goods kami's got guts you got
to give him that they got guts
yeah
but yeah so and also like we talked
about this earlier but um but bondarenko
the guy that died in the uh oxygen-rich
capsule like after he threw the alcohol
soaked cotton ball yeah
um that was 1961 like right before Yuri
garen's a space flight so they kept that
a secret for a long time but that
actually came out later on too like
because like I said they didn't really
like anybody knowing that like people
had died during this kind of stuff
there's also another conspiracy this
isn't necessarily about like a dude that
died but there are a lot of conspiracy
theories that Yuri Gagarin was maybe not
the first man in space there's a theory
that uh actually the first man in space
was another Soviet guy named Major
General Vladimir ilushkin illusion yeah
I don't think there's a K in there and
he was a test pilot and he apparently
was the first cosmonaut in space I don't
know if this is true or not but that's
there's like a rumor going around now
lynnwood's Lynnwood Sly says the Space
Shuttle Enterprise is the first Orbiter
of the space shuttle system rolled out
September 17 1976 it was built for NASA
because I am right
but it didn't go up on its own though it
didn't I remember they were carrying it
around on the back of a 747. I don't
know if it ever launched I don't think
it ever launched on its own okay well he
says it's an Orbiter
that's what I'm saying I don't know I
just remember like seeing Colombia like
going up and they made
you know what I'm saying I don't I don't
know they might be able to clarify that
like look it up on Wikipedia you got
like a tablet right there
you know okay
it's making me work okay oh my goodness
that's terrible that you have to work
okay [ __ ] I work every like 24 seconds
space shuttle
Enterprise
but yeah so the whole story about this
guy was that the story goes I don't know
if this is necessarily true or not no it
was me without a ninja yeah see there he
was not capable of space flight yeah
okay
that's what I thought yeah like I said I
was there but that's the one I remember
that [ __ ] it had the pointed pointed
tail too but I'm just saying that that
didn't like long time Colombia was the
first one okay
1981 I was there like I said I saw the
[ __ ] I grew up in Florida don't tell me
that [ __ ]
what the hell I'm just saying okay I'm
not getting [ __ ] on them I'm getting
[ __ ] on you because you're trying to
tell and I remember that's what you're
trying to tell me that it's like that's
the that's the one I remember as a we
lad okay is that it was Enterprise and I
was watching it fly around on a [ __ ]
747
I didn't know it it never launched yeah
it didn't launch look at the like the
regular time
I saw Columbia launch the first time in
1981. all right
but yeah so
um so basically this guy uh Vladimir
illusion
he was a test pilot and a general
and he was kind of like got sucked into
this he's a real guy like he does exist
but he got sucked into this whole
conspiracy theory that he was actually
the first man in space other than rather
than Yuri Gagarin
Now The Story Goes that
what really happened it seems like was
that illusion was in I guess like a car
accident or he was at some kind of like
car accident like not too long before
Yuri gearen's flight
and the conspiracy theory grew up that
this car crash was actually like um a
cover story for
an orbital space flight which had gone
awry he didn't die obviously but what
ended up happening so The Story Goes was
that
he um actually like crashed in China I
believe and they're basically like and I
don't know like the mission went wrong
so the Soviets were just kind of like
well we can't have that so we're just
gonna pretend that didn't happen like he
crashed in China and he was like really
really injured and so they were like
well the mission wasn't a success so
we're just gonna like we're just gonna
like say that he yeah he was in a car
wreck or something like that so there's
a persistent conspiracy theory that he
was actually like the first one in space
but there's actually no record of any
launch around that time
um because you know other people did
know like when you launched some [ __ ] it
wasn't like it was a secret or anything
so they they don't think that's entirely
true but that is a very like persistent
uh conspiracy theory
now um 1967
as we mentioned earlier uh there was
another Cosmonaut who got killed when
the parachute on the uh Space Capsule
failed to open
now uh the thing about it too was that
Yuri Gagarin himself actually was killed
in 1968 uh not in space but he was
training like on a fighter jet and uh
got killed during an accident during
that so he was killed as well
um but the thing about I think when most
people talk about this whole lost
Cosmonaut thing what they're usually
talking about is the very persistent
urban legend
that all of these fatalities that now we
know about
um are maybe only like a very small
percentage of the total number of people
who died
um and some people actually even argue
that not only did a bunch of cosmonauts
die but a bunch of them like are still
floating around up there in space
someplace which like I said is a very
very creepy idea for a lot of people
so one of the things that first started
all of this
in 1960 uh Robert Heinlein obviously
very famous sci-fi writer he said that
he was traveling around the USSR and he
met some Red Army Cadets and they told
him in 1960 that there had recently been
a manned space launch
and they said that the launch capsule
which is called the corable Sputnik one
I think I'm sure I'm butchering
butchering that pronunciation
um they said well when they were
launching it there was like a a
mechanical failure and because the
guidance system steered it in the wrong
direction and they couldn't actually
like retrieve the capsule so this uh
capsule is actually stranded in an orbit
around the Earth and it's still like out
there nowadays by Major Tom which yeah I
kind of feel like they probably just got
it from from that well although this was
before that song yeah but it wasn't it
Bowie ripped this off yeah
well like I said it's a I don't want to
say it's a romantic idea but it is kind
of like an idea it's a compelling idea
uh the fact that there might be somebody
maybe there's like skeletons out there
like floating around space but like I
said nowadays
it's less likely that you get away with
something like that because they would
detect
if there was something out there
floating around that just had like
skeletons in it for example
um they would know that was out there
because there's a bunch of spaceship
there's a bunch of space junk and they
can compute what it is that's what I'm
saying they know that's a booster from
[ __ ] 1972. right they know what it is
or that's like that Soviet dog that was
yeah capsule or whatever or that monkey
or whatever like floating around how did
those things die from lack of oxygen I
imagine yeah yeah but it's like ran
around barking until they ran out of
oxygen I would I you know what I would
honestly rather send a shitty person
into space than a dog yeah like if
you're gonna do the whole time
that's what I mean it's like that's
[ __ ] up with what dogs didn't do
anything to anybody
send some [ __ ] people out there
there's a lot of people that [ __ ]
deserve it well they only did it like
once they wanted to see if it killed you
you know just wanted to know spoiler
alert it does no they wanted to see if
launch killed you
that's the thing that they're still like
floating around out there right well
they that's why they started with dogs
and monkeys and stuff they were like
well we don't have to worry about
getting them back right which again
[ __ ] up but I would like you said I
kind of feel like you'd rather like send
prisoners up there because you don't
really care if they come back
my brothers would be enough
even mice I'd rather send like zero
because let's send BTK let's send BTK to
space yeah I would rather send vtk up
there than mice or dogs mice and dogs
didn't do nothing to anybody BTK did
some [ __ ] to some people
let's send him up there you want to go
Dennis
who is this back there oh stop stop
[ __ ] around Jenny does he want to go
to space yeah you want to get Space
Janice if I go to space then [ __ ]
what Are You Gonna Learn by me going to
space everybody knows about space
want to learn something send me to
church
[Laughter]
early church give me a nice broad
wearing pantyhose
no we're in a mechanics we're gonna send
you this space and you're not coming
back let me show you the Minotaur
no thanks
yeah I'll pass hard pass actually
so so yeah so uh Highline says that he
hears all these stories about yeah they
launched some [ __ ] and it's like they
didn't really want to tell anybody they
[ __ ] up so now there's like all these
dead cosmonauts like floating around out
there like in in orbit so I mean they
didn't have any evidence of it it was
just like stories that he that he heard
yeah Soviet citizens would think that
though
because of all the people killed on
launch pads and all the accidents so
they would think there'd be a bunch of
[ __ ] astronauts up there cosmonauts I
mean but that's not necessarily the case
yeah they did cover up a bunch of stuff
and so I can understand like why people
be like oh well if they've never got all
that up then there must be some other
stuff yeah but I don't know if that's
necessarily the case Americans thought
that yeah now Americans thought that and
it's like I said it's not dumb to think
that because they did try to cover some
[ __ ] up because it seemed like they
covered up
I mean they know about it now and it was
just kind of like just regular ass like
accidents and horrible like tragedies
and stuff like that but the thinking was
is that the Soviet Union only announced
a successful space mission after it
happened or during the mission
so
and then the ones that were unsuccessful
you never heard about them so therefore
they thought that there must be like 10
unsuccessful ones for every successful
one that you heard about
well what happened to the other ones you
know what I mean that that that's where
this that's where this is coming from
well yeah that's what I'm saying which
that makes sense yeah yeah but probably
not as bad as but not necessarily the
case right I kind of feel like it's
human nature too hey if you lied about
this one thing then you lied about these
other five crazy things but that's not
necessarily the case you know what I
mean like all of the stuff that's been
Declassified they're like yeah like and
I've talked about a few of them on the
show it's like yeah all this [ __ ] up
[ __ ] happened but that doesn't mean that
like oh worse should happen that they're
still covering up that's not necessarily
based on air follow based on my studies
that I remember and I remember [ __ ]
studying this [ __ ] when I was a kid
Military Academy
not only the Soviets but also the
Americans
most of the accidents happened on the
ground during training and [ __ ]
rehearsals and research yeah that's
where most of it happened well both
that's where most of the [ __ ] happened
here well like I said technically only
if you yeah only three people have died
in space technically most of the time
it's in like while they're launching or
Landing or something like that that's
like the most a lot of it's researching
ideas yeah yeah certain thing will
happen so they're doing on their own
test rage and that [ __ ] [ __ ] blows up
boom it kills [ __ ] seven or eight
guys oh I guess we can't do that
yeah live and learn I guess we can't do
that and then you never hear about that
being associated to the Space Race but
they're right they're developing engine
yeah in Rocket Fuel a lot of it had to
do with the development of Rocket Fuel
is it going to be hypergolic fuel
which that's two or three things you
just add together and it blows up or is
it going to be something based at
hydrogen you know what I mean which is
safer but you got to ignite it it's not
self-igniting you know it's that kind of
[ __ ]
that hypergolic fuel [ __ ] research
that went back in the 30s back in
[ __ ] old mustache man Nazi Germany
and that was deadly research if you were
on hypergolic fuel all right
just storing the [ __ ] could kill you it
was [ __ ] highly corrosive it was pure
one of the elements was pure
pure
um hydrogen peroxide
if you got any of that on you it would
reduce you to pink foam and bones
so just handling it was [ __ ]
dangerous
you
the Russians had guts but so did the
Germans back in those days they were
[ __ ] crazy when it came to technology
you know they were like Dr Strange Love
You Know
why don't we take their [ __ ] sea
stuff and tea stuff mixed together to
the hypergolic you know it's the way
they were you know
well just put the pilots in a rubber
suit it'll work out
and if it doesn't it doesn't I'm sure
they didn't really know when they're
playing Rex there's all this Twisted
[ __ ] aluminum that cuts through the
rubber suit and the [ __ ] fuel gets on
the pilot so then you just end up with a
rubber bag fill the [ __ ] pink foam
and bones
but and again they were probably like ah
live and learn yeah again they didn't
really give a [ __ ] they didn't really
[ __ ]
Good Times
well in lack of empathy lack of humanity
that was probably a factor as well I'm
sure
it was World War II
everybody was dying sure and you know
I'm not saying that Jeff yard said I
agree with Jenny we need to have
convicted Killers but use this test
subject think of all the medical
advancements we could make hey like if
look if if that [ __ ] is like confessed
to the [ __ ] and they have DNA and
everything like that
ditto I'm not saying I don't want to
give him reward though you got to give
him an out why would they volunteer if
it was certain deaths yeah I don't think
you should force them I mean like even I
don't even think that but it's like
I don't know like if they wanna it's
like hey you want to actually like do
something good for people in your whole
miserable life since you've made
everyone's life so terrible like you've
made the world a worse place so do you
want to rectify that maybe you could
come at him that way I think maybe most
of them wouldn't care because like I
said they're sociopaths so they don't
give a [ __ ] about anybody else they
don't give a [ __ ] about helping anybody
but yeah so um so yeah so Robert
Heinlein hears the story now the Soviets
officially they said well we did do a
launch uh but there wasn't a guy on it
it was an unmanned uh test flight that's
all that was all it was there were
there's not like guys out there like
floating around the tin can like Major
Tom like I said
um but heimline was like no I think
there's a cosmonaut in there I don't
know if he had any evidence he just
wanted to think that maybe I don't know
um now let's kind of talk about too like
because I kind of feel like he pointed
as evidence he's like hey there's these
two very famous Italian brothers who
were amateur radio operators who
allegedly picked up a bunch of radio
Transmissions that they claimed were
from Soviet space launches which didn't
go so well so let's talk about yeah I've
heard the recordings they're ominous
they are but I was listening to one of
the most famous ones and it didn't I
don't know it doesn't sound authentic to
me I know that's like maybe
she doesn't sound panicked enough
I don't know you know what I'm saying
it's just kind of like she's just
reporting back that she could see the
Earth it's getting hot in here
yeah it's like I'm so hot I'm so hot
she's like that like it's in Russian
obviously but you know you can like
listen to [ __ ] it's on YouTube you can
like listen all that stuff but yeah I
was listening to that earlier today
so okay so in case you guys don't know
there was these two Italian brothers uh
akele and Giovanni Bautista and they got
fascinated by radio Transmissions you
know they were kind of like dorks about
that so they set up their own
experimental listening station uh just
outside Turin in the late 1950s
and they kind of set up their [ __ ] in uh
what's like a disused German bunker
um at a site called the Torah Bert Torre
Bert something like that
so they basically like put together they
just like scrounged equipment or like
they didn't have a lot of money so they
just kind of like cobbled [ __ ] together
and they claimed uh that they had
successfully monitored Transmissions
from the Soviet Sputnik program and
Explorer one which is the first uh
American satellite in 1958 uh which you
know they had their cobbled together uh
you know equipment that they recorded
the [ __ ] from
so in the 1960s
these two brothers
started releasing recordings which they
claimed were radio communications from
Secret Soviet Union space space missions
and several of these space missions
according to them
uh were
astronauts that uh were lost in space or
were killed in space and that the
Soviets did not acknowledge had actually
occurred
now in total they call these the judica
judica Cordelia brothers that's what
they call them
uh they actually released nine
recordings Over a four-year period
um and they claimed that a lot of these
were from Lost Soviet missions
so may of 1960 they allegedly picked up
evidence of an unnamed Cosmonaut uh
becoming Lost in Space when his orbiting
Space Capsule veered off course so
apparently he's still floating around
out there someplace and they said that
they got a transmission from him
November of 1960 uh they said they
picked up an SOS Transmission in Morse
code which was also coming from a Soviet
spacecraft
and they said that based on the
Transmissions they said the craft was
actually moving away from Earth instead
of orbiting it
uh and they surmised that the Soviets
had accidentally launched these
cosmonauts deep into space which seems
like it would be hard to do
just saying those are two completely
orbiting Earth and like going off in a
deep space
that's what I'm saying
uh so February of 1961 they also claimed
that they recorded the uh a cosmonaut
suffocating to death will you resist 61
61. okay so it's not as not as old as I
thought it was okay
how old do you think I thought that was
in the 50s late 50s no they started
building their [ __ ] in the 50s okay um
and monitoring stuff in the late 50s but
all of the Soviet stuff they supposedly
started in like 1916. yeah all right uh
so may of 1961 uh they claimed that they
had got like uh that they recorded these
very weak calls for help from an
orbiting capsule
and later that year in October they uh
purportedly heard evidence that a Soviet
spacecraft veered off course and
vanished into deep space again so
they're kind of like going off into
nowhere
uh in November of 1962 allegedly uh they
also said that they recorded evidence of
a Space Capsule bouncing off the Earth's
atmosphere during re-entry and
disappearing which I'm not even sure is
possible
yeah how do you record that that's what
I'm saying so in one of the recordings
probably the most famous one yeah uh
from November of 1963.
uh and you can hear it on YouTube it's
everywhere
there's a woman's voice and she can be
heard saying in Russian uh that she can
see Flames yeah and asking Mission
Control if her ship is about to explode
um saying stuff like I'm hot I'm hot I'm
hot like over and over again like as
though the capsule is like burning
burning up yeah now if these recordings
are genuine
uh then it means that uh the Soviets had
actually launched not only the first
woman in space
um but you know but also that she was uh
you know kind of died there also so yeah
they're talking about re-entry yeah and
then maybe they didn't have the [ __ ]
uh the bottom of the capsule correct
usually I think it's cast iron I think
back in those days and then later on
it's a space shuttle type tiles
so maybe they didn't have the heat
shielding proper
and she's getting hot
I suspect
that it's a hoax but I think they would
have known about heat shielding that's
what I'm saying unless the angle of
attack the angle of Entry of The Craft
might have been wrong but the thing is
is that that's happened before that's
what happened to the Space Shuttle that
isn't a long process if the angle is
incorrect
on the [ __ ] re-entry
it just burns a [ __ ] hole right
through the ship like quick there isn't
any of this well it's getting warm in
here
no it comes through there like a [ __ ]
blowtorch that's what I'm saying I don't
know if you'd necessarily have time
because every time the recording I heard
the one that was on YouTube is like
almost three minutes long and I don't
think that you would have time to no if
an unprotected part of the ship
something like that it gets hot quick if
there's an unprotected part of the ship
going through re-entry it just burns
right through it [ __ ] instantly
and then the internal [ __ ] PR the
internal temperature of that [ __ ]
module would [ __ ] go up into the
thousands of degrees quickly
there wouldn't be any time to talk about
it it wouldn't be any gradual warming up
yeah and I got the and I don't know like
listening to it I don't speak Russian
obviously but um
it is but I don't think she doesn't
sound
I don't know it just sounds very I don't
know it just sounds very funny well a
professional would be calm it's just I
don't yeah but there's something about
it that just doesn't sit right with you
and chances are a female russian a
female cosmonaut
would be doing something more along the
lines of [ __ ] giving out temperatures
and numbers
well see now that's another thing she'd
be doing something she'd be doing
something like it'd be going through
it'd be going through uh
some kind of a [ __ ] re-entry
procedure that they've given her and
she'd be transmitting [ __ ] data off
of her damn control panels or her the
readings off of her [ __ ] sensors
to help the ground crew prevent the next
that's what I'm saying to prevent the
next accident well like I said that's
what they all do most of them like I
said I'll get into that in a second most
of them died giving back data
um there's also another rumor that
swirls about uh the Soviet cosmonauts
being uh technically the first people on
the moon uh because there was a group of
them volunteering to be launched
directly into the moon on the Soviet
Luna probe which was like a one-way
Mission which I also think is [ __ ]
but yeah that's enough I misspoke urban
legends I said most of them died trying
to get back data that's not what I meant
most of them would have died trying to
give back data that's what I meant by it
because that would have been a
cosmonauts number one Mission priority
is to send data back
to help the mission
to prevent it again
I can't tell you that they died doing
that what's his name died talking to his
wife
but they knew they didn't need any
information from him they knew his
altitude they knew we were wrong
you know
but chances are she'd be given trying to
give back data not saying boy it's hot
they're like yeah duh [ __ ]
should be back there giving something
something useful to the ground crew
well that's the thing so even though
like all these stories came out like
these Italian brothers and they got kind
of got famous
um the Soviets came out and said yeah
none of that [ __ ] happened which oh they
came out and said well the thing about
it is like all the stuff that they said
didn't happen like later on they came
out and said yeah this happened and that
happened like all the stuff that I
talked about earlier but the stuff that
the Italian brothers said that they
recorded they're like yeah that [ __ ]
didn't happen so I so I don't know but
like I said you can see how why like why
because they had covered up some things
yeah so they're like well you know maybe
they're covering up this [ __ ] as well
but the thing about it is that the
recordings nowadays are by most accounts
um seen as like forgeries or the Italian
brothers were just kind of like trying
to [ __ ] around or trying to like get
famous you know what I mean because most
of the stuff now here okay here's a fun
fact
in 1964 the brothers they were like real
into space you know what I mean yeah and
they won uh a prize on an Italian quiz
show called The Fair of dreams and they
got to go to NASA as the prize and they
were like super excited about that I
thought that was like super super funny
yeah
um but even Yuri Gagarin was like
um I don't think like he's like all of
this [ __ ] like even if they actually did
pick up these radio transmissions and
they're not fake
um he's like a lot of that could be
explained by accidents that happened in
low earth orbit it's like nobody went
off into space nobody did anything like
that
um they've actually done even back in
the 60s they started doing kind of like
critical analysis of the recordings and
even back then people were like thinking
they were full of [ __ ] it's creepy
though well they are creepy I'm not
saying that but they're just saying that
they're probably not real
they're saying that none of the
cosmonauts that they that these guys
supposedly recorded
um
none of them were following like then
you kind of alluded to this just now
none of them were following standard
communication protocols like none of
them like identified themselves or they
didn't use the right like technical
terminology or anything like that
um and they said that a lot of the
recordings also contained like uh
grammatical errors something that a
native Russian speaker would not have
said so there was that as well uh so
people started to think maybe it was
like kind of [ __ ]
now the thing about it too and I think I
talked about this earlier was that some
of the transcripts record Cosmonaut
saying that oh my God we're leaving
Earth's orbit like accidentally like
heading into deep space or whatever
um but they said that the
the spacecraft that this allegedly
happened on uh were not capable of going
into deep space like I said it's two
different things like orbiting the Earth
and blasting out on a deep space you
need like different technology for that
and they're like so all of the [ __ ] that
the Soviets were capable of doing at
this time period they wouldn't have been
able to accidentally send somebody in a
deep space really it's just like a
different I don't know it's just it's
something that probably wouldn't have
happened
so they think that a lot of the uh those
Italian recordings were probably faked
they were just probably trying to get
famous or whatever
um and like I said everything
supposedly everything from that era the
Soviet era has been Declassified at this
point
uh so they so they don't know it's like
it's possible that some of that should
happen but it's doubtful there were a
couple also of hoaxes like confirmed
hoaxes I love this
so what happened with this one was that
officially soyuz two remember we talked
about uh soyuz before but soyuz 2 was
supposed to be an uncrewed spacecraft
and it was supposed to be like the
docking Target for soyuz 3. they had
like all these missions going on
now what happened with this was that
there was somebody on there whose name
was supposedly Yvonne is oh God is
stocknikov is stocknikov I guess I'm
pronouncing that right
uh so this guy was supposedly on this
Mission but what they found out later on
in 1993 was that this person
did not actually exist like the whole
story was that him and his dog whose
name was cloca
uh were supposedly Manning this
spacecraft and they disappeared in 1968
and supposedly the ship had been hit by
a meteorite and then the Soviets had
like erased them from history which they
did do for for some people but so that
was the story
what they found out later on though
was that this whole story had been
cooked up by a
artist
essentially like as an ARG right
um this person named uh Joanne font
cuberta came up with this whole and it's
pretty genius when you think about it he
came up with this whole Modern Art
installation
and he had like a whole bunch of uh
falsified Mission artifacts like
digitally manipulated photos and all
these like biographies so he made it
like totally look real like I said so
like an energy
um but they didn't find out until
several countries media had reported it
as like a real thing
that going on as well uh so this
this whole art installation was actually
shown in Madrid in 1997 and uh was at
another Museum in Spain in 1998. but
apparently some other countries didn't
get the memo that this was a modern art
installation and reported it as like a
real thing that happened
um even though it was not but everybody
got got it sorted out like later on but
it took a while it took a while
there was also another uh case of a guy
named Andre mccoyan and he was
supposedly killed uh him and another
crew member when they were trying to get
to the moon ahead of the Americans in
1969 uh there was a system malfunction
and uh they didn't land on the moon they
just like shot past it you know what I
mean so there was a story about that so
that was like an urban legend that was
going around uh particularly in 2000 I
kind of feel like that was a legend that
was going around and they think uh
there's no evidence of this actually
occurring and they think that maybe this
story started circulating around this
time because there was a television
series called the cape and there was an
episode of that called buried in peace
that first aired in October of 1996 and
it had like a very similar storyline so
it could have been that you know people
were just remembering that as a
documentary or they were just
remembering it and just disseminating it
as an actual story but they think that's
probably where that came from so they
know that that's probably that but
the Lost cosmonauts thing I don't know
it's not crazy to think that
maybe there were a few missions that
went like drastically awry and they
still don't want to talk about and that
maybe those Italian brothers like
recorded some evidence of it but I don't
know the [ __ ] that they've Declassified
um they're pretty sure they've got all
the [ __ ] nowadays and yeah some bad [ __ ]
happened but they kind of know about it
now so there's always going to be some
people saying no no no no they totally
erased this one and that one and there's
a bunch of secret programs
but could they could you actually hide a
secret program I mean there's budgets
and [ __ ] that's what I mean like now I
kind of feel like
I mean from everything that I could find
from the thing they're like we
understand why people would think that
because the Soviets did try to cover
[ __ ] up for a long time
but they're like now that everything has
been Declassified it's like it would be
really difficult for something of the
magnitude
of because when you launch some [ __ ]
into space it's not like you can just
launch your [ __ ] into space and nobody
knows about that stuff here's another
thing that here's another thing that
would uh kind of add to what Jenny's
saying
the Soviet Union is gone
the modern Russians of today are not
like the Soviets uh there's a big
difference
but they're still Russians
and they're going to want their
ancestors to be recognized as their
lives being lost in some of these
[ __ ] tests exactly so they're at this
point in time they're not gonna hide
them there's no incentive anymore the
incentive would be more towards no
exposure who died in the pursuit of
Soviet greatness that would be more so
now what Jenny Sands right so I kind of
feel like most of the [ __ ] that's come
out like about the guy like that fell to
Earth and the guy that died and the
testing and the three guys that died in
the capsule like now all that's come out
that was all secret back in the old days
yeah but now everybody knows about it
yeah there were there with Jenny's right
there's going to be more
there's going to be more of an
inclination for the modern Russians to
get the street cred yeah of all the
people that died yeah so they wouldn't
they wouldn't want to hide it they'd
want to show that's what I'm saying
they'd want to show because it's not
like it used to be it's not like it used
to be and uh they're not trying to hide
failures now they would be exposing
bravery This Is How brave we were well
this is how many of our people died
trying to get to space because you could
you could use that as a talking sure so
that's what they would be doing and you
know what I mean like I said before you
know I don't give a [ __ ] what you all
think about what's going on I always had
a lot of respect for the Russians I was
friends with Russians right ex-russian
soldiers they're a good people there are
very good people they're tough they got
balls they're not like us but they're
not supposed to be like us they're not
Western
but that's not saying Western being
Western that's not everything people
have a right to be who they are you know
what I mean the Chinese are Eastern
they're going to be that
that's their prerogative that's that's
their culture the Russians are just
Russians they've been around for
thousands of years they're a lot older
than us let them be Russians you know
they have their own culture their own
value system
let the chips fall where they made
Hugo says people are weird Israel India
and China went to the moon in 2017 took
pics of all the Apollo Landings and some
people still think it was fake well
the thing about conspiracy theories is
that once you get real uh kind of like
drilled down to the [ __ ] yeah I kind of
feel like there's a sunk cost fallacy
kind of thing going on at work once you
put so much of your emotional time and
energy into a particular conspiracy
theory you'll go to Great Lengths to not
have that taken away from you because
you don't want to feel like you've
wasted your entire life on something
that is essentially stupid yeah but the
thing about like not landing on them
it's like what would even have been the
point of that well here's another thing
a lot of those people from the
conspiracy we didn't go to the Moon
conspiracy is they think that there was
only one attempt no they went like many
times
well and the thing about it too is I
kind of feel like people that
actually believe that the moon landings
were fake yeah I kind of feel like they
don't know about they don't know the
other ones I think they went like six
times
but like I said people that are really
invested in those kind of things yeah
they don't want to know anything that's
outside of that bubble you know what I
mean so it's like if you look into the
actual history of what it took like to
actually get to the moon and like if you
know a lot of the [ __ ] like behind it
you would never think that [ __ ] was fake
because why the [ __ ] would they bother
no you know what I mean it just seems
like it was easier just to go ahead and
go than it was that's what I'm saying
it's like to me it just seems like it
would be a lot more difficult to like
fake it like why would you even bother
doing that yeah it was not that hard my
granddad was involved it was not that
hard the the highest technology thing
they had was a very simple computer that
failed that was like a couple of [ __ ]
circuits it was like a calculator there
wasn't much it didn't do much your cell
phone was [ __ ] millions of times more
powerful than what they had on that damn
[ __ ] the [ __ ] litter module you
know there was nothing really there it
was amazing mostly mechanical I mean it
was just like put together it was like
mechanical paper and spit and prayers
they went there just [ __ ] pure
[ __ ] fuel they just burned fuel to
get there
if you really think that [ __ ] was fake
like seriously look into the history
like all the contingencies and
everything like that yeah well like I
said everything like we've talked about
this a lot in the show
history is a lot more complicated it's
very nuanced it's very complicated
there's all kinds of like different
little contingencies and [ __ ] like that
and I understand
the human need to make everything simple
because you want to get your like
[ __ ] head around it because humans
didn't evolve for all of this
complicated [ __ ] yeah so I understand
the need for people to be like oh we
need to Simply it must be like a simple
explanation it's never a simple
explanation it's always like a million
little [ __ ] things that could have
gone differently at any point and I kind
of feel like it's I don't know man it's
just like I don't it just makes me mad
that like all these people are just like
yeah
thousands and thousands of people were
involved yeah in that whole mission yeah
and the fact that you're just like
[ __ ] on all those people's Legacy
just being like oh it was all faked it's
like it would have been harder to fake
it like you said yeah than just going
but that was a popular Topic in a lot of
movies from that time I know it was is
that that it was fake I know uh but that
was like that was like a Trope I know
you know what I mean so that it kind of
it's kind of lit it it's kind of believe
it even Stanley Kubrick guy like roped
into doing tropes and [ __ ] yeah no they
went oh The Shining was like he was like
talking about how he helped fake the
moon landing I'm like come on dude like
how [ __ ] high are you right now yeah
that you're even saying that they spent
so much money you know they went to the
moon because on the back of all that
[ __ ] technology they did the [ __ ]
space shuttle which was I I don't agree
with it they should have stayed with
that [ __ ] Saturn technology due to
the Saturn heavy lifting Rockets were
[ __ ] the [ __ ] we'd had all kinds of
stuff in Space by now
I mean because to be honest with you I
think in most iterations yeah it's much
more difficult
to lie and maintain a facade of Lies
than it is to just kind of like tell
everybody hey this is what happened yeah
I mean that's not always the case but I
do kind of feel like
I mean even in your regular life you
know this if you start lying about some
[ __ ]
eventually you're gonna get to a point
where it's just too much trouble to
maintain this fiction that you have
constructed
um when you should have just told the
truth to start with because it's like
much easier so I kind of feel like
that's true of most things yeah that's
true people just don't want to realize
that really the [ __ ] went to
the Moon in space it was just white boys
in Russia and the United States in
[ __ ] ties with short sleeve shirts
and pocket protectors with [ __ ] up
glasses than just talking about it and
writing it down they figured it out
that's all it was they figured it wasn't
the technology wasn't that high just the
map it really wasn't it was just the
math and the [ __ ] and the money they
figured it out that was most it was it
was math and money that's really what it
mostly was
and will willpower
it was a dick competition between Russia
I mean if you have the money and the
wherewithal yeah and the intelligence
yeah you can do pretty much anything you
set your mind to yeah you know what I
mean like within parameters obviously
but I don't know like why
I don't know what people get out of not
thinking people went to the moon I'm
like even if they didn't go it's like so
what well like why does that how does
that affect your life no they're there
because they're telescopes powerful
enough to look at the [ __ ] lunar
Landing site so you could see them from
Earth you can see them
come on yeah and it's just I just kind
of really heard some of the satellites
can actually see the footprints they
came
like nowadays you really have to do some
[ __ ] and roundabout like you really
have to kind of like
go all the way around like to to make
that if you want to maintain that
conspiracy theory in your head you
really have to like reach the real
mystery about the Moon is not whether or
not [ __ ] walked around on it
with boots you know [ __ ] [ __ ]
little Russian white boys and American
white boys that's not the mystery the
mystery is is are there [ __ ]
monuments placed on it
billions of years ago or millions of
years ago from civilizations that
existed before us probably not
that's what they need to look for
there's enough time
there's enough time that maybe even
before it is even before the dinosaurs
and all that stuff maybe there was an
alien there is but that lived here that
went there that's that's what it is I'm
not saying it's impossible yeah I'm just
saying that it's an extraordinary claim
and so it needs extraordinary evidence
go on the moon and look for an old
Monument
trillions of years old they're going to
go up there and find like the [ __ ] I
would find they're gonna I would they're
gonna find the Statue of Liberty yeah
you blew it up you blew it up for the
monolith from [ __ ] 2001 but I would
look for uh I would look for
um magnetic [ __ ] fields
you know what I mean to see if there's
anything up there if there's some kind
of because if you're going to build a
[ __ ] Monument
with the intent of having it be fouled
you'd probably [ __ ] put
big ass magnets in it or something
something that could be detected
I don't know we just that's just my I
mean I would have think that I would
have thought that they would have found
it by now if that was the case evidently
they haven't really closely searched all
the [ __ ] satellite footage of the
surface
and uh you know there's been a lot of
bombardment over the trillions of years
so it's it's probably underneath the
surface I mean to be honest the Moon is
kind of like I know it's uh in inorganic
uh object but the Moon is kind of like a
hero because the moon takes a lot of the
bombardment that otherwise would have
hit Earth
so you could argue that the fact of the
Moon being there is maybe the reason
that life was able to develop on Earth
because the moon was like taking all the
bullets yeah but I'm not talking out my
ass people I [ __ ] listened I checked
I listened to [ __ ] like channels like
Event Horizon and have scientists on
there there is enough time in the
Earth's history
to where there could have been a whole
other Genesis
before the dinosaurs before this oh yeah
I'm not saying that plenty of that time
there yeah that's totally possible we're
we're and evidently it like could have
happened several times over where there
may have been something up it was it's
been a long time there may have been
space-faring races lived here trillions
of years ago that maybe left something
on the moon so I would check the moon
because that's more preserved I mean I
don't think any nobody evolved there no
no but I'm saying astronauts from here
years ago left something on the moon for
us to find or they left behind some kind
of piece of technology that may have
survived because it's not in the
elements it's up there in the vacuum
yeah so it would last for a long long
time but it would be submerged by now
probably
but like I said that's an extraordinary
claim so it needs some extraordinary but
there's a lot of time in the past but
I'm open to that idea because like that
would be more likely than finding a
[ __ ] active
extraterrestrial civilization on a
nearby star it would be more likely to
find some on the Moon from a long long
long time ago
yeah
that would be more likely
Mark says when they finally landed on
the moon all they found was two empty
bottles of moonshine and Tom's wallet
now while it was goddamn empty
that leather wallet behind I got the
credit card stacked the [ __ ] little I
was good I was gonna say I was gonna say
it was empty because you went to the
moon and spent all your money come on
titty bars onto yeah on titty bar titty
bars
[Laughter]
Jenny wanted to know when I'm coming
back
I would never ask you that she doesn't
care about what I do
yeah go to the Moon Yeah have a good
time have a good time [ __ ]
all right so what's up don't get any
like sexually transmitted disease don't
bring back no STD from like the moon for
crazy because I don't I saw your sister
wife today when I went run down to
[ __ ] store my sister wife your sister
yeah yeah wait who's Amy Amy the [ __ ]
the the bartender from the biker bar
well I don't know her though yeah she
hasn't met you yet she wants to meet you
that's what I mean she goes boy your
girlfriend got some big ass titties
because she said yeah she wants to be
it's [ __ ] funny you guys have to see
it to understand it but [ __ ] uh no
she was still she's over at the dollar
store she's like what you doing here and
it's just I gotta get uh um
he went to the dollar store again
what you doing here since I gotta get
mixers for the for the [ __ ] uh show
tonight and she says go okay tell your
girlfriend I said hi as she said
yeah she loves me she doesn't yeah she
didn't know she's seen pictures of you
though
she saw the blue wig and [ __ ] and she
loved that [ __ ] wig
she doesn't know how delightful I am in
person no you're probably mean to her if
I [ __ ] if I bring her over here no I
wouldn't she lives across the street
does she really yeah she lives across
the street yeah she she said what you
doing she goes I'm buying stuff from my
daddy she takes over here I have some
drinks with us yeah
okay she takes care of her dad her dad's
[ __ ] um super fat and can't walk and
has like all kinds of leg problems and
[ __ ] she owns one of them Farms across
the street oh okay yeah you told me that
yeah yeah she was over there I thought
you said you were gonna fight her over
like yeah but you know what I mean she
never gets around to it she's like yeah
okay
I'm gonna show you guys home maybe she
thinks we're like serial killers no no
no no
I'll show you guys what I'm talking
about
she's funny we gotta put her on the show
she'd be hilarious on the show your
glasses are yeah I know they [ __ ] up I
ordered new ones and [ __ ] it's just
making me laugh yes
okay hold on what the [ __ ] man Zach says
uh that reminds me on ubereats the top
two picks for Wings around here are
hooters and a titty bar downtown called
Twin Peaks I think Twin Peaks is a chain
because I think we have one
yeah we have one like um
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
save me yeah she's the she's the
bartender at the biker bar
here's another cute picture ever and she
just lives right around here she lives
across the street
well like I said the biker bar is just
yeah yeah not that far away
that was funny that you saw her at the
dollar store yeah she's at the dollar
store she said what you doing here
it's like what do you think she's super
[ __ ] redneck you'd like her she's
funny she's like some somebody from like
back in the day you know
listening to Free Bird and [ __ ]
aren't you guys tired of that song oh
[ __ ] sick of it actually she likes
the castle
she knows about the castle
everybody knows about this yeah yeah in
Florida she saw a picture our picture
because oh you guys must go to the
castle because I have been a castle in
years
yeah yeah
Danny only says tiggle Bitties what's
that T-Mobile yeah
yeah you know they're all boob sisters
Zach says oh she's cute yeah no I'm not
lying let's say you know
she's nice well like I said she'd come
over bring her over yeah bring her I'll
bring her over we'll have some drinks
yeah I'll put her on a show she's
[ __ ] hilarious
yeah maybe we should never do a show
maybe we should have her maybe we should
have her here for like a Sidetrack show
yeah I could do something like that yeah
funny yeah I mean if she wants to I
don't want to like make her be she's
kind of bashful but she that's what I
mean I don't want to make people be on
the show yeah if they don't want to be
because I know it's kind of just funny
I know it's kind of like be nice you'd
like it stressful yeah
I think Tom would like Mission to Mars
I've heard of it
I've heard it is that a ride at Disney
World no I think it's a movie well I
know it's a movie too yeah and I thought
it was like which reminds me did I
mention this yeah
um on Sunday some of you guys know I
went to Disney with my sister
and they're doing their Halloween thing
so like you were allowed to go in at
four and like you could uh at six they
kicked all the other people out and then
they had like the Halloween party and so
like some of the rides had different
skins on them so what they did was Space
Mountain
was it Space Mountain they kind of like
put all these like crazy lights on the
outside and you know how Space Mountain
like is normally like it's a roller
coaster but it's like dark inside but
they're still kind of like lights
but what they did for the Halloween
thing was they turned every single light
off so you're on Space Mountain but it
is completely utterly pitch black yeah
so me and my sister are on the [ __ ] and
wow that that was something else that
was something else you could absolutely
not see a single [ __ ] thing do you
want a breakfast sandwich
sure I got breakfast sausage eggs
waffles
I got cheese
I got [ __ ] I got
wait you're gonna put a waffle on the
breakfast what'd you do what you do or
you can put waffles the bread and then
you put all right you put sausage egg
are you going that way and then you put
it and then you then you put some some
syrup on it on the inside like a
condiment how about that and you eat it
like a sandwich
because I got those [ __ ]
toaster waffles
that'd make good bread
yeah I probably would yeah now that
you're talking about yeah and maybe like
two eggs on it each one sound good I'm
down all right I'm gonna make them then
Zach says I looked at the castle on
Google Earth once and the first pick I
saw of the inside yeah was some chicken
leather gear on a table having her boobs
groped by a guy in a mask yeah yeah yeah
yeah just go on YouTube and look at
Castle videos I mean the castle has been
there forever it's a Florida institution
yeah uh the building is super cool I
think it used to be Masonic it was a
masonic lodge like back in the old days
Ybor city was like an old it used to be
all like cigar factories and Pirates and
[ __ ] like that so it's like a really
cool building it's like really big and
it's two stories and has stained glass
windows and the whole [ __ ] [ __ ]
Zach says oh God breakfast sandwiches
sound so good sound good it does doesn't
it okay we're gonna make them all right
so hopefully you guys have enjoyed this
crazy creepy space show I had a good
time doing this one actually I didn't
know if I was gonna be all that into it
but I was just kind of like oh this is
this is kind of fun
but yeah so hopefully you guys have
enjoyed it as much as I enjoyed it and
we will see you guys again on ooh Friday
for the Side Tracks show which will be
I don't know we'll have to go to the
liquor store and see if we can find like
some weird some weird tricks to come up
with for Friday but uh yeah thanks for
dropping by everybody and hanging out
with us this Wednesday evening we will
see you again on Friday night good night